Freddie is the general manager of a car dealership these days, but he used to be a car salesman. And he was a good one, partly because he's got what he calls the gift for the gab. His go-to move in lots of situations is to finish his sentence and then laugh, even when the sentence is bad news. Like, here he is assessing his chances of making his sales goal for the month.
弗雷迪最近是一家汽车经销商的总经理，但他以前是一名汽车销售员。而且他是个优秀的销售，部分原因是他拥有所谓“能说会道”的天赋。他在很多场合的招牌动作是说完话后大笑，即使那句话是坏消息。比如，这里他在评估自己达成当月销售目标的机会。
I'll give it a 50/50 right now because it's early.
我现在给它打50/50，因为时间还早。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Or this is him talking about a month when the car dealership did not make its sales goal.
或者这是他在谈论汽车经销店没能达到销售目标的一个月。
And I'm strictly commission, so I make nothing.
我完全靠佣金，所以我什么都没赚到。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So when Freddie is not laughing, you know it's bad. In mid-October, Freddie did not laugh much at his weekly meetings with the guys who sell cars for him.
所以当弗雷迪不笑的时候，你就知道情况很糟。十月中旬，弗雷迪在每周与手下销售员的会议上没怎么笑过。
All right. Good morning. All right. In the beginning of the month, I went through the room and I told everybody where they had to be. Jason, you have 16 cars out. You need 10 more for the month for 26. I want to see you there.
好了，早上好。好了，月初我巡视了整个房间，告诉每个人他们需要达到什么目标。杰森，你卖出了16辆车。这个月还需要卖10辆才能达到26辆。我想在那看到你。
Bob Lundy, you have six out. You need nine more. Scotty, you're at 10 right now. You need to be at 18.
鲍勃·伦迪，你卖出了6辆。你还需要卖9辆。斯科蒂，你现在是10辆。你需要达到18辆。
Last month, they didn't make their sales goal. That was September. The first week of school is always bad for car sales in the suburbs. They were supposed to sell 127 cars and trucks. They sold 82. So they have to make October.
上个月，他们没能达到销售目标。那是九月。开学的第一周对于郊区的汽车销售来说总是很糟糕。他们本应卖掉127辆汽车和卡车，结果只卖了82辆。所以他们必须拿下十月。
And when I say have to make, this is not some sort of abstract, feel-good, "compete with the dealership down the block just for fun" kind of competition. They're part of Chrysler. And if they sell 129 cars and trucks by the end of October, Chrysler will pay them a bonus that's pretty much the difference between the dealership being in the black or being in the red for the month, somewhere between $65,000 and $85,000, depending on which models they sell. Different cars earn different amounts. If they sell 128 cars, fall just one car short, they get nothing.
当我说是必须拿下时，这并不是某种抽象的、感觉良好的，“为了好玩而与街对面的经销店竞争”那样的竞争。他们是克莱斯勒的一部分。如果他们在十月底前卖掉129辆汽车和卡车，克莱斯勒会付给他们一笔奖金，这笔奖金几乎就是该经销店当月是盈利还是亏损的区别，大约在65,000美元到85,000美元之间，具体取决于他们卖的是什么车型。不同的车赚取的金额不同。如果他们卖出128辆车，只差一辆，他们就什么也拿不到。
That's the worksheet that Chrysler sends us to show us what money we can earn by how many cars we sell.
那是克莱斯勒发给我们的工作表，用来向我们展示通过销售多少辆车我们可以赚到多少钱。
And there's a new one every month?
每个月都有新的吗？
Every month.
每个月都有。
In the middle of the month, the owner of this dealership, a sweet-faced guy named Marc Brodlieb, and Freddie, show me the document where Chrysler set their October sales goal.
月中，这家店的老板，一个面容和蔼的家伙叫马克·布罗德利布，和弗雷迪给我看了克莱斯勒设定他们十月销售目标的文件。
No. No. This changes every month.
不，不。这每个月都在变。
At their whim.
随他们的意。
And that's another frustration. We have no idea what the number's going to be and really how they compute it. We've had numbers as high as 159. And we fight and we go crazy. It's cockamamie, if anyone knows what that means.
这也是另一个挫折。我们根本不知道数字会是多少，也不知道他们到底是怎么计算的。我们甚至遇到过高达159的数字。我们抗争，我们发疯。如果有人知道“cockamamie”（荒唐）是什么意思的话，那就是它。
Because basically they shift around the ground rules on you.
因为基本上他们会随意改变基本规则。
Every month.
每个月。
What makes this tricky is that there are four other Jeep dealerships within 10 miles of Marc and Freddie, and Marc says that most customers will shop price at two or three of them. So to stay competitive, Marc and Freddie do what pretty much everybody else does. They set lower prices, knock hundreds of dollars off the price of the cars, sometimes sell them for less than they pay Chrysler for them, with the hope that they're going to hit their sales goal and get the bonus to make up the difference.
这事棘手的地方在于，在马克和弗雷迪的店方圆10英里内还有四家Jeep经销商，马克说大多数客户会在其中两三家进行比价。为了保持竞争力，马克和弗雷迪做了几乎所有人都在做的事情。他们设定更低的价格，从车价中砍掉几百美元，有时甚至以低于他们付给克莱斯勒的价格卖车，希望他们能达成销售目标并获得奖金来弥补差价。
But there's no guarantee we will hit this number. So the pressure is huge because we have already given away the money to the consumer, using that to sell the car.
但不能保证我们能达到这个数字。所以压力巨大，因为我们已经把钱让利给消费者了，用那个来卖车。
So I need a big day today. I need a big day, no bull. I really need a big day today.
所以我今天需要大干一场。我需要大干一场，不吹牛。我真的需要今天大干一场。
So with 12 days left to go in the month, numbers wobbly, Freddie laid it on thick during his weekly meeting with the sales team. He told them he sees them over the dealership's security cams.
所以，在离月末还有12天的时候，数字动摇，弗雷迪在每周与销售团队的会议上施加了巨大的压力。他告诉他们，他通过经销店的监控摄像头看着他们。
I look through the video. I watch you guys in there. All on your computers, going to different websites, chilling. Dude, get on higher gear. This is no joke. I've got to be at that number, or I'm telling you, I'm not going to be a nice guy. So put your nose right to the ground and come out shooting today, everybody.
我查看视频。我看着你们在里面。都在电脑上，浏览不同的网站，放松。伙计们，上档次。这不是开玩笑。我必须达到那个数字，否则我告诉你们，我不会是个好说话的人。所以每个人都给我埋头苦干，今天火力全开。
I want balloons in all the departments. I want the radios down on. Put the convertible tops down all over the place. I want tons of balloons in the showroom. I just don't want one balloon to a car. Balloon the whole freaking place so it looks like a circus.
我要所有部门都挂上气球。我要把广播调小。把所有地方的敞篷车顶都放下来。我想要展厅里有成吨的气球。我不想一辆车只配一个气球。把整个鬼地方都塞满气球，让它看起来像个马戏团。
Make it seem like we're having a monster sale and it's a party, because we've got to be at the big number by the 31st, midnight, period, no ands, ifs, and buts.
让它看起来好像我们正在举行一场盛大的特卖会，是一场派对，因为我们必须在31号午夜前达到那个大数字，期限到了，没商量，没借口。
So everybody grabs balloons. Grown men inflate and tie and decorate. It's a truism in their business, balloons sell cars. And then nobody shows up for an hour, two hours, three hours-- four hours. Saturday should be one of their busiest days, and it's empty.
于是每个人都去抓气球。成年男人充气、系绳、装饰。这在他们的生意里是一句真理，气球能卖车。然后一个小时、两个小时、三个小时……四个小时过去了，没一个人来。周六应该是他们最忙的日子之一，但店里空空如也。
Hey, Freddie. How's it going today so far?
嘿，弗雷迪。今天到目前为止怎么样？
Shit. Really bad. Really slow. Really, really slow.
该死。非常糟糕。非常冷清。真的，真的非常冷清。
Early afternoon, Freddie told one of our producers, Brian Reed, that it was way slower than usual. I don't know if you can catch this, but try to notice the song that is playing over the radio in the background as they talk.
午后，弗雷迪告诉我们的制片人布莱恩·里德，生意比平时慢多了。我不知道你们能否听出来，但试着注意他们在交谈时背景广播里播放的歌。
What do you think it is? What's going on?
你觉得那是什么歌？发生了什么？
Not a clue. With all the advertisings out there and everything else, we should be swamped. I'm stressing. Oh, I'm stressing.
一点头绪都没有。有那么多广告和其它一切，我们本该忙得不可开交。我压力很大。噢，我压力很大。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[MUSIC - "DON'T WORRY BE HAPPY" BY BOBBY MCFERRIN]
[音乐 - 鲍比·麦克菲林的《Don't Worry Be Happy》]
Marc, who owns this dealership, and Freddie, who runs it, both know that most people do not trust car dealers. Most people think that they're ripping us off, throwing on extra charges, milking us for every dime. And they say, if you and I only knew the reality, we would see that, in fact, the dealer is not making a killing off us. In fact, the dealer is often squeaking by with a very thin profit margin. They say it is all very different from what people think. And to prove their point, they let us watch.
拥有这家店的马克和管理它的弗雷迪都知道，大多数人并不信任汽车经销商。大多数人认为他们在宰我们，额外收费，榨取我们的每一分钱。他们说，如果你我知道真相，就会发现实际上经销商并没有从我们身上大捞一笔。事实上，经销商往往利润空间极薄，勉强维持。他们说一切与人们想象的完全不同。为了证明这一点，他们让我们旁观。
A bunch of us from our radio show, we recorded them as they headed towards the end of the month, trying to make their goal, trying to sell 129 cars, which, you know, you would think that would be very straightforward, very businesslike. After all, new cars and trucks, they're 15% of all retail sales. But if what we saw was typical, what that means is that hundreds of billions of dollars in economic activity and nearly 2 million jobs exist thanks only to millions of messy seat-of-the-pants deals, many of which barely come together, as salesmen sweat out their end-of-the-month quotas. It is way more chaotic than we expected.
我们广播节目的几个人记录了他们走向月末的过程，努力达成目标，试图卖出129辆车，你知道，你本以为这会是非常直接、非常公事公办的。毕竟，新车和卡车占了所有零售额的15%。但如果我们所见是典型的，这意味着数千亿美元的经济活动和近200万个工作岗位仅归功于数百万笔混乱的、临时的交易，其中许多交易几乎无法达成，正如销售员们为月末指标而流汗。这比我们预期的混乱得多。
And we saw things, it's true, we think will surprise a lot of car buyers. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Today, one car dealership tries to sell 129 cars. We get to know the resolute men and women who try to pull that off.
而且我们看到的东西，没错，我们认为会令很多购车者感到惊讶。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。今天，一家汽车经销商试图卖出129辆车。我们要了解那些试图完成这一壮举的坚定的男男女女。
Quick note, this show is a rerun. Everything you'll hear in this hour all happened in October a couple years back. Stay with us.
简短说明，本节目是重播。你在这一个小时内听到的所有内容都发生在几年前的十月。请继续收听。
So I wish I could pretend that we got interested in this subject at our radio show because we realized what an important part of the economy car sales are. And I wish I could pretend that we did a huge survey to find the most typical dealership out there. But in fact, we got interested in this topic and this particular dealership-- Town & Country Jeep Chrysler Dodge Ram is what it's called, in Levittown, New York, on Long Island-- when one of our coworkers here at the radio show, Robyn Semien, bought a used car there.
我希望我能假装我们对这个主题感兴趣是因为我们意识到汽车销售是经济中多么重要的一部分。我也希望我能假装我们做了一项大规模调查来寻找最典型的经销店。但事实上，我们对这个话题和这家特定的经销店——名为Town & Country Jeep Chrysler Dodge Ram，位于纽约长岛的莱维敦——感兴趣，是因为我们广播节目的同事罗宾·塞米恩在那里买了一辆二手车。
Here's how that happened. A friend of hers who knows all about cars told her that the only vehicle that she should even consider for her young family is the Honda Pilot. So she went looking online. She saw one listed on cars.com. It was at Town & Country.
事情是这样的。她的一位非常懂车的朋友告诉她，她唯一应该考虑给年轻家庭买的交通工具就是本田Pilot。于是她上网查找。她看到cars.com上列出了一辆。就在Town & Country。
And she called. And she had no intention at all of going to look at the car. But a salesman convinced her, oh, you know what? You should come out today, right today. Talked her into it, which meant an hour-long ride on a train from Brooklyn with her husband and her four-year-old.
她打了电话。她根本没打算去看车。但一位销售员说服了她，噢，你知道吗？你应该今天就出来，就今天。说服了她，这意味着她要和丈夫以及四岁的孩子从布鲁克林坐一个小时的火车。
And then once she got there, they upsold her to a newer, more expensive vehicle, a Jeep Liberty, which she drove off the lot 24 hours later. Robyn told me this story in the car in question on our first ride out to the dealership.
等她到了那里，他们向她推销了一辆更新、更贵的车，一辆Jeep Liberty，她在24小时后就把车开了回去。在我们第一次去经销店的车里，罗宾告诉了我这个故事。
Yeah. I mean, the Honda Pilot, I think, is across the board, less problems, lasts longer, better gas mileage.
是的。我是说，本田Pilot，我认为，总的来说，问题较少，寿命更长，油耗更好。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I know. I know. I know. I know, but I love this car.
我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道，但我就是喜欢这辆车。
You got that? These people are such good salesmen, not only did she pay more, not only did they put her into a Jeep, which meant that, since they are a Jeep dealer, they could sell her a warranty, which they also did for a few thousand dollars, she came out of this loving her car and loving them. How did they do this?
听到了吗？这些人是如此优秀的销售员，不仅她付了更多的钱，不仅他们让她买了一辆Jeep，这意味着，既然他们是Jeep经销商，他们可以卖给她一份保修，他们也确实这么做了，花了她几千美元，她从这里出来时还爱上了她的车，也爱上了他们。他们是怎么做到的？
Well, before we go any further, I think I should give you a quick primer on the basic setup and cast of characters at this dealership. New cars are sold at Town & Country-- and we're going to be spending most of our time with new cars today-- by seven men and one woman, who, by the way, constantly make fun of each other in this raunchy way that we cannot play you over the radio. Just know that that's happening.
好吧，在我们继续之前，我想先给你简要介绍一下这家经销店的基本设置和人物阵容。Town & Country销售新车——今天我们大部分时间将花在新车上——的是七名男性和一名女性，顺便说一下，他们不断以一种我们无法在广播中播放的下流方式互相取笑。只要知道有这回事就行。
Plus, there are two guys in the finance department. And then, overseeing all of them, there are the general manager, Freddie, who you already met, and then, out on the showroom floor all day, every day, are two managers who you're going to be hearing from a lot over the course of this hour. These are Mike Perez and Sal Lanzilotta.
此外，财务部有两个人。然后，监督他们所有人的是总经理弗雷迪，你已经见过了，然后，每天整天在展厅地板上的，是你在这一小时内会听到很多的两位经理。他们是迈克·佩雷斯和萨尔·兰齐洛塔。
Of the two, Sal is the more complicated figure. Balding, with a gray goatee, he's got this vibe that is halfway between Ben Kingsley in Gandhi and the laconic hitman Mike from Breaking Bad. When Sal gets up to speak at the weekly sales meetings-- the meeting, by the way, is in the middle of the showroom-- he paces around a red convertible as he talks, reminding everybody of the basic tenets of car sales.
两人中，萨尔是一个更复杂的人物。秃顶，留着灰色山羊胡，他身上有一种介于电影《甘地传》中的本·金斯利和《绝命毒师》中那种冷漠杀手迈克之间的气质。当萨尔在每周销售会议上发言时——顺便说一下，会议是在展厅中间举行的——他一边说话一边围着一辆红色敞篷车踱步，提醒大家汽车销售的基本准则。
Customer says they're not ready to buy a car. They're all not ready to buy a car. Let's go over it again. They're in a car dealership.
客户说他们还没准备好买车。他们都没准备好买车。让我们再过一遍。他们在一家汽车经销店。
They got in their car, drove through hell to get here, looked for a parking spot for 10 minutes, parked, got out of the car, and walked into a car dealer. Not because the coffee's good. We went over this. Because the coffee here is not good. They came here because we sell cars, and they want to buy one.
他们坐上车，经历了地狱才来到这里，找了10分钟停车位，停车，下车，走进一家汽车经销商。不是因为咖啡好喝。我们说过了。因为这里的咖啡不好喝。他们来这里是因为我们卖车，而他们想买一辆。
Nothing's changed in a hundred years of selling cars, he tells them at one meeting. The customer wants to pay as little as possible. We want to make as much as we can.
卖车一百年来什么都没变，他在一次会议上告诉他们。客户想付尽可能少的钱。我们想赚尽可能多的钱。
You guys know the job, right? You've all done it before.
你们都知道这份工作，对吧？你们以前都做过。
Be aggressive.
要积极。
Be aggressive. ABC, Bob. What's ABC?
要积极。ABC，鲍勃。ABC是什么？
Always Be Closing.
始终保持成交（Always Be Closing）。
Always be closing.
始终保持成交。
OK. So these guys, the managers, Sal and Mike, sit near the front door of the showroom at this elevated platform that everybody calls the podium or the desk, and they oversee all the terms of all the deals.
好的。所以这些家伙，经理萨尔和迈克，坐在展厅前门附近那个被称为讲台或服务台的高台上，他们监督所有交易的所有条款。
And if you've ever bought a car, maybe you've wondered what really happens when the salesman leaves you and they go back and they talk to their manager, they talk to the boss. What do they do? Well, what they do is, we were told, they load their lips. Here's Freddie.
如果你曾经买过车，也许你好奇过当销售员离开你，回到后面去和他们的经理、和老板交谈时，到底发生了什么。他们做了什么？好吧，我们被告知，他们是在“装填嘴唇”（向销售员授意）。这是弗雷迪。
We tell them what to say to the customer. And we load their lips, send it back to the customer, and see where we can commit.
我们告诉他们该对客户说什么。然后装填他们的嘴唇，把他们送回客户那里，看看我们能达成什么。
So for instance, when one of the salesmen wants to get a woman to bring her husband in today to test drive the car that she's chosen, they huddle at the desk, a bunch of them, and Freddie starts to improv some lines for the salesman to say.
所以，例如，当其中一位销售员想让一位女士今天就把她丈夫叫过来试驾她选中的车时，他们一群人挤在服务台，弗雷迪开始即兴创作一些台词让销售员去说。
Listen, if you can take this car by Monday, what happens-- if I can. I'm not sure if I can do it. I have money for the weekend that I'm giving away from Chrysler. As long as you purchase it by tomorrow and pick it up by Monday, you win.
听着，如果你能在周一前提车，会发生什么——如果我能的话。我不确定我能不能做到。我手里有周末的钱，是克莱斯勒给的优惠。只要你在明天前购买，周一前提车，你就赢了。
He's totally making this up. There's no weekend money like this.
他完全是编造的。根本没有什么周末优惠。
I've got extra money over the weekend through Chrysler. I want to use it. I want to give it to you. Get your husband in here.
我周末有克莱斯勒提供的额外资金。我想用它。我想给你。把你丈夫叫过来。
And with that, the salesman heads off.
就这样，销售员出发了。
That's loading the lips. You've just seen it. Loading your lips.
那就是装填嘴唇。你刚亲眼看到了。装填你的嘴唇。
But before the managers can load their lips, they have to figure out what price they're going to ask for and the terms of the deal and all that. And this works differently, I think, than the way that most of us imagine is happening when we buy a car. We assume that the managers and the salesmen are a unified team, and it's us versus them.
但在经理们装填嘴唇之前，他们必须弄清楚他们要索要的价格、交易条款等等。我想，这和我们大多数人在买车时想象的情况不同。我们假设经理和销售员是一个统一的团队，是我们对抗他们。
But in fact, managers and salespeople are often at odds with each other, and they spin information and they lie to each other. Here's Peter Possas, a very experienced salesman, who, at the time of this recording, was three cars shy of the 18 that he was supposed to sell in October. And what he's doing here is he's asking a couple what they want their monthly payments to be on a new car.
但事实上，经理和销售员往往意见不合，他们会编造信息并互相撒谎。这是彼得·波萨斯，一位非常有经验的销售员，在录音时，他距离十月应卖出的18辆车还差3辆。他在这里做的是，他在询问一对夫妇他们希望新车的月供是多少。
What if I can get you the same payment you're at now? $199 for 39 months, something like that?
如果我能让你获得和现在一样的月供呢？39个月每月199美元，大概这样？
OK, hear that? $199 a month. Then Peter marches over to talk to the managers at the desk. And listen to the number that he tells Sal that the customer wants.
好的，听到了吗？每月199美元。然后彼得走过去和经理们谈话。听听他告诉萨尔客户想要的数字。
She wants it to be about $150 a month.
她希望每月大约150美元。
$150. Not $199. As soon as Sal is out of earshot, Peter turns to the reporter who's trailing him, Sean Cole.
150美元。不是199美元。一旦萨尔走远，彼得转向跟踪他的记者肖恩·科尔。
You see what I did?
看到我做了什么吗？
So talk me through it.
跟我说说看。
You heard-- well, you saw what-- she told me she wants to be at $199 a month.
你听到了——嗯，你看到了什么——她告诉我不想要每月199美元。
Right.
没错。
But I'm telling him $150 because I've got to work him, too, at the same time I'm working her.
但我告诉他150美元，因为我也得对付他，同时还要对付她。
Oh, so you're going lower with him.
噢，所以你对他说了一个更低的数字。
Yeah.
是的。
I see.
我明白了。
Why do this? Well, later, when the negotiations get tough, the manager, Sal, may ask Peter to squeeze the customers for a lower number on their trade-in, or maybe a higher price for the car, something that might be hard to talk the customer into. But Peter now has wiggle room. He knows he can push the couple up to $199 a month in payments because they already said yes to it. He can make up the difference there.
为什么这么做？好吧，后来，当谈判变得艰难时，经理萨尔可能会要求彼得挤压客户，让他们降低以旧换新的价格，或者要求更高的车价，有些事情可能很难说服客户。但彼得现在有了回旋余地。他知道他可以把这对夫妇的月供推高到199美元，因为他们已经答应过这个数字。他可以在那里补回差价。
In fact, as the deal proceeds, it runs into a problem. The desk, the couple, and the salesman cannot come to an agreement about how much the dealership should pay the couple for their trade-in. Sal says it is worth one price. The customers say that another Jeep dealer offered them a lot more than that for the trade-in. But of course, that may be a lie. There's a saying in the business-- buyers are liars. Or maybe the other dealership is lying to the customers. Maybe the other dealership told them an unrealistically high price that they never intend to pay. That happens, too. Everyone is playing everyone.
事实上，随着交易的进行，它遇到了问题。服务台、这对夫妇和销售员无法就经销店应该为他们的旧车抵价多少达成一致。萨尔说它值一个价。客户说另一家Jeep经销商给他们的抵价高得多。当然，那可能是一个谎言。生意场上有句话——买家都是骗子。或者可能另一家经销店在对客户撒谎。也许另一家经销店告诉了他们一个不切实际的高价，而他们根本没打算支付。这种情况也会发生。每个人都在算计每个人。
Sal, at the desk, tells Peter, the salesman, that the customer cannot be getting that trade-in price from the competitor. It can't be true.
在服务台的萨尔告诉销售员彼得，客户不可能从竞争对手那里得到那个抵价。这不可能。
Stop believing what the customer's telling you. That car does $16,500 at the auction. There's no way they're paying him $20,000 grand on a car that they could sell at auction for $16,500.
别再相信客户告诉你的话了。那辆车在拍卖会上只值16,500美元。他们不可能付给他20,000美元买一辆他们在拍卖会上只能卖16,500美元的车。
Then I guess he's a better negotiator than me.
那我想他是一个比我更好的谈判者。
I think he's just a better liar, and you're buying it.
我想他只是一个更好的骗子，而你上当了。
Yeah.
是的。
That's the difference.
这就是区别。
So to summarize, the managers and the salespeople are playing each other. The customer is playing them both. Each dealership is playing the other dealerships. And the manufacturer is playing all the dealerships, with its quotas and its incentives. Chrysler sold 140,083 cars and trucks in October. This is what it took to sell one of them.
总结一下，经理和销售人员在互相对抗。客户在算计他们俩。每家经销店都在算计其他经销店。而制造商则用其配额和激励手段在算计所有的经销店。克莱斯勒在十月卖出了140,083辆汽车和卡车。这就是卖出其中一辆所付出的代价。
Like I said earlier, several of us came and recorded at this dealership and each of us chose different salespeople to follow. Robyn Semien chose Bobby Tantillo. A warning to listeners, somebody uses a word in an offensive way in her story. We're going to leave that in because we're trying to document what really happened.
正如我之前所说，我们几个人来到这家店录音，每个人都选择了不同的销售员跟随。罗宾·塞米恩选择了鲍比·坦蒂洛。给听众一个警告，她的故事里有人用了冒犯性的词汇。我们会保留它，因为我们试图记录下真正发生的事情。
Robert Tantillo-- Bobby T around the dealership-- is in last place. He doesn't like talking about it.
罗伯特·坦蒂洛——店里的鲍比·T——排在最后一名。他不喜欢谈论这个。
How many cars have you sold?
你卖了多少辆车？
I can't keep track.
我记不住。
I know someone here is keeping track.
我知道这里有人在记。
Well, then you'd have to ask them.
好吧，那你得问他们。
I didn't have to ask them. Freddie makes it clear in that weekly speech he gives every Saturday. Remember that meeting? He goes over everyone's individual sales, gives them new goals. Bob's there that morning, too. Freddie is keeping track.
我没必要问他们。弗雷迪在每个周六的演讲中说得很清楚。还记得那个会议吗？他翻阅每个人的个人销售额，给他们设定新目标。鲍勃那天早上也在场。弗雷迪在记着呢。
Bob T, you're at three. Thanks for stopping by.
鲍勃·T，你卖了3辆。谢谢你的光临。
Bob doesn't flinch. He sits poker-faced in a chair. A couple of guys look down or stare at their hands.
鲍勃没有退缩。他面无表情地坐在椅子上。有几个人低头看着手。
I want 15, Bob. 12 more.
我要15辆，鲍勃。还得12辆。
Bobby T's new here. Before this, he was in the wholesale food business for three decades, became a car salesman a few years ago after he retired. Bob says last month, he had the most sales for a couple weeks. But last month was last month. Freddie needs this month.
鲍比·T是新来的。在此之前，他在批发食品行业干了三十年，退休后几年前成了汽车销售员。鲍勃说上个月，他有两周是销售额最高的。但上个月是上个月。弗雷迪需要这个月。
Bob says the issue is, there's just so much about selling cars that's out of his control. He says his biggest problem this month is a lack of leads. One way salesmen get leads is from the internet. Town & Country lists all the cars it has online.
鲍勃说问题在于，卖车这件事有太多他无法控制的东西。他说他这个月最大的问题是缺乏潜在客户。销售员获取潜在客户的一种方式是通过互联网。Town & Country在线列出了所有的车。
When people see one they like, they usually call before they come in to make sure the car is really there. But those calls go to guys in the back, in the internet department. Then when the customers show up at the store, they meet whoever they talk to on the phone, and one of the bosses at the desk hands them over to a real salesperson, like Bob. Except that Bob says he's never been handed one of those leads.
当人们看到喜欢的车时，他们通常会在来之前打电话以确保车真的在。但那些电话转到了后台的互联网部门。然后当客户出现在店里时，他们会见到在电话里谈话的人，服务台的老板之一会把他们转给真正的销售员，比如鲍勃。除了鲍勃说他从未被转接过那些潜在客户。
They're going to give it to a guy that they know is-- that's been here. And they feed him the deal. That's pretty much how it works.
他们会把它给一个他们认识的——一直在这儿的人。然后他们把交易喂给他。差不多就是这么工作的。
You have to really be tight with the desk.
你必须和后台的关系非常紧密才行。
Yeah.
是的。
Bob's not tight with the desk. But Freddie, in an attempt to help out, gives Bob exactly what he wants-- his first internet lead. He tells Bob, go on back, get Dan. Dan works in the internet office, so these words-- "go get Dan"-- that's the signal for taking over an internet lead.
鲍勃和后台关系不紧密。但弗雷迪为了帮忙，给了鲍勃他想要的——他的第一个互联网潜在客户。他告诉鲍勃，去后面，找丹。丹在互联网办公室工作，所以这些话——“去把丹找来”——就是接手互联网潜在客户的信号。
Freddie raises his eyebrows at Bob and nods his head slowly like, you got that? Bob misunderstands the cue. He gets Dan from the internet office, who comes up to the desk to greet the customers and hand them off to Bob, who has suddenly disappeared. No one knows where he went, so Freddie gives the customers to another salesman. A bewildered Freddie calls over to Dan.
弗雷迪向鲍勃挑眉并缓慢地点点头，像在说，听懂了吗？鲍勃误解了暗示。他从互联网办公室找来丹，丹走上服务台去迎接客户并将他们转手交给鲍勃，但鲍勃突然消失了。没人知道他去了哪，所以弗雷迪把客户给了另一个销售员。困惑的弗雷迪对着丹喊道。
And I sent Bob T over there to get you or whatever and then come back. Where'd he go?
我派鲍勃·T去那边找你或者什么的，然后回来。他去哪了？
He buzzed. So I said, you busy? Come on. He kept going to the office.
他按了蜂鸣器。所以我说，你忙吗？来吧。他一直往办公室走。
He's like retarded. He's retarded.
他像个弱智。他是个弱智。
He came over to me.
他来到我这。
I know. I told him, go get Dan. Come right back.
我知道。我告诉他，去把丹找来。马上回来。
Bob walks up minutes later.
鲍勃几分钟后走了上来。
The whole idea was to get Dan and come back and then take over the sale. That's what Dan does.
整个想法是去找丹，然后回来，然后接管销售。那就是丹做的。
I thought you wanted me to get him. That's what I thought.
我以为你想让我去找他。我就是这么想的。
Well, that's what Dan does. He comes in. He gets the sale, and then he gives it to the salesman. So instead, now Manny got it.
好吧，那就是丹做的。他进来。他拿到销售，然后给销售员。所以现在，曼尼拿到了。
I'm sorry. I was talking to Chris about the [INAUDIBLE].
对不起。我正在和克里斯谈论那个[听不清]。
Yeah, exactly. Three cars out. I would.
是的，确实。三辆车出去了。我会的。
It's hard to watch someone with a lot of experience berate someone with much less experience for not knowing better. There's a line from the movie Glengarry Glen Ross. "You never open your mouth till you know what the shot is." When you don't know the shot, it's not like you don't want to know the shot. Bob doesn't know the shot. But he's trying.
看着一个经验丰富的人指责一个经验少得多的人因为不知道窍门而责备他是件很难受的事。电影《拜金一族》里有一句台词：“不到你知道窍门时，不要开口。”当你不知道窍门时，并不是你不想知道。鲍勃不知道窍门。但他正在尝试。
He didn't say, there's a customer here. Take care of the customer. He said, go get Dan. So I went and got Dan. I was supposed to know what he's thinking.
他没说，这里有位客户。照顾好客户。他说，去把丹找来。所以我去把丹找来了。我本来应该知道他在想什么。
It's hard. You get bullied. You get pushed around. But you let it go, move on. It's a tough job, and it's not for everybody. I told you that.
这很难。你会受到欺负。你会到处碰壁。但你让它过去，继续前进。这是一份艰难的工作，不是每个人都适合。我告诉过你。
You've got to be thick-skinned. You've got to be able to take a lot, absorb a lot. He said, well, now we gave it to the other guy. OK. What do you want me to say?
你必须脸皮厚。你必须能够承受很多，吸收很多。他说，好吧，现在我们给了别人。OK。你想让我说什么？
So there actually is a place at Town & Country where they keep score of who has sold what. It's in Freddie's office, the general manager's office. It's a whiteboard with each person's sales for the month to date on it. Every car or truck that they've sold is represented by a little magnetic rectangle that's roughly the size of a 9-volt battery. Everybody calls these chips. And the different colors of the chips stand for different models of cars and trucks.
所以Town & Country确实有一个地方记录着谁卖了什么。就在弗雷迪的办公室，总经理办公室。那是一块白板，上面有每个人当月到目前为止的销售额。他们卖出的每一辆车或卡车都用一个大约9伏电池大小的小磁矩形表示。每个人都称这些为“筹码”。筹码的不同颜色代表汽车和卡车的不同型号。
And throughout the day, salesmen come and they hover around the whiteboard, seeing where everybody stands. And generally, everybody is shooting for at least 15 sales a month. At 15 sales, your commission for the next month jumps from 20% to 30%.
整天都有销售员围着白板，看每个人处于什么位置。总的来说，每个人都在争取每月至少销售15辆。销售15辆时，你下个月的佣金会从20%跳升到30%。
There's also a bonus of $600 when you hit 10 cars, $250 if you sell seven cars in the first two weeks of the month. There's money you get directly from Chrysler, and that could be anywhere between $50 and $250 per car. Mid-level salesmen here and Town & Country make around $60,000 a year. Top performers are closer to $100,000. Most of that is commissions and bonuses.
销售10辆时还有600美元的奖金，如果在月初两周内卖出7辆则有250美元。有从克莱斯勒直接获得的钱，每辆车可能在50到250美元之间。Town & Country的中级销售员一年大约赚60,000美元。顶尖业绩者接近100,000美元。大部分是佣金和奖金。
The number one salesman at Town & Country is always the same. Some months, he has twice as many sales as whoever's in second place.
Town & Country的头号销售员总是同一个人。有些月份，他的销售额是第二名的两倍。
I've been doing this 28 years. This guy is one of the best I've ever seen.
我干这一行28年了。这家伙是我见过的最好的之一。
That's salesman Peter Possas standing at the board. It's the middle of the month.
那是销售员彼得·波萨斯站在板前。那是月中。
He's got 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8-- 15, two pending. 17 cars. Unbelievable. This guy's a born salesperson.
他有1，2，3，4，5，6，7，8——15辆，两辆在处理中。17辆车。令人难以置信。这家伙是天生的销售员。
All the veteran sales guys at Town & Country say these things about this guy. He also happens to be the youngest salesman of dealership. He's 28. Jason Mascia. Reporter Sean Cole followed him around.
Town & Country所有的资深销售员都这样评价这家伙。他恰好也是店里最年轻的销售员。他28岁。杰森·马西亚。记者肖恩·科尔跟随他四处走动。
Jason stands out from everybody else on the sales floor in pretty much every way. He's taller than everybody else and way more focused on his appearance-- always a full suit and tie, double Windsor knot, gelled hair. He's handsome. And he isn't just the best seller at Town & Country. He's one of the best sellers of Jeeps, Chryslers, Dodges, and Rams in America.
杰森在销售大厅里几乎在各方面都引人注目。他比谁都高，而且对自己的外表非常注重——永远是全套西装打领带，双温莎结，抹发胶。他很帅。而且他不仅是Town & Country最好的销售员。他也是美国最好的Jeep、克莱斯勒、道奇和Ram销售员之一。
So I'm going to go on my login here. And then, boom.
所以我登录我的账号。然后，砰。
He showed me this internal Chrysler company website that ranks all the salespeople.
他给我看了这个克莱斯勒内部公司网站，对所有销售人员进行排名。
I'm talking thousands of people. You see this national number? There is 29,000 salespeople in the whole entire country.
我在谈论成千上万的人。你看到这个全国数字了吗？全国共有29,000名销售员。
And you're--
而你是——
I'm 108.
我是第108名。
108 out of 29,000.
29,000名中的第108名。
You have a shocked look on your face.
你脸上露出震惊的神情。
Yeah, because I look at it and I say, that's freaking crazy. You know what I'm saying? You would think a guy that's in this business for 15 to 20 years should be doing that stuff.
是的，因为我看着它说，这真是太疯狂了。你知道我在说什么吗？你会认为一个在这个行业干了15到20年的人才应该做到这一点。
Jason's barely been in this business for four years. When I met him in the last weekend of October, he had already outsold everybody for the month, including a guy who's been doing this since Jason was a toddler. But he says he's not competing with the others. He's competing with himself.
杰森进入这个行业才刚满四年。当我在十月的最后一个周末见到他时，他已经领先所有人，包括一个杰森还是蹒跚学步的孩子时就一直在干这一行的人。但他说他没有和别人竞争。他在和自己竞争。
I'm trying to excel. I have my own goals that nobody would even know about. You know what I mean? So I'm like my own little celebrity in my own little body.
我在努力超越。我有自己没人知道的目标。你懂吗？所以我像我自己身体里的小名人。
As we're sitting there talking, he pulls out a piece of paper and starts writing down everything he's saying as he says it. He always does this. I have 10 pages of notes from this interview-- his notes.
当我们坐在那里交谈时，他拿出一张纸，开始写下他说的每一句话。他总是这样。我有这次采访的10页笔记——他的笔记。
So most of the salespeople at Town & Country are shooting for 15 to 20 sales in a month. That's considered a solid performance. And Jason is not satisfied with a solid performance.
所以Town & Country的大多数销售员都在争取每月15到20辆的销售额。那被认为是一份扎实的业绩。而杰森对扎实的业绩并不满足。
There's a number that I really want to hit.
有一个数字我真的想达到。
He writes down that number and circles it and then moves on.
他写下那个数字并圈起来，然后继续。
And I would love to just achieve-- I have achieved 30 cars several times.
我很乐意达成——我曾多次达成30辆车。
Writes down 30, underlined "several." That is, 30 cars a month.
写下30，在“多次”下面划线。也就是说，每月30辆。
All right? So I've done that enough to say I could do it. Now I'm trickling--
好了吧？所以我做过足够多次，可以说我能做到。现在我正在朝着——
Writes down 30, plus sign.
写下30，加号。
--30-plus.
——30以上。
For October, hoping to finish the month in the mid-30s somewhere. But Jason's own personal Olympic goal?
对于十月，希望能以30多辆结束这个月。但杰森个人的奥林匹克目标呢？
Say what this number is that you wrote down.
说说你写下的这个数字是什么。
This is 40. 40's a big number. You know what I mean? If you could hit 40 cars, that's more than a car per day. That's sick. That's crazy, especially when you're selling cars. You know what I mean? It's not like I'm selling suits.
这是40。40是一个大数字。你知道吗？如果你能达到40辆，那超过一天一辆车。这太变态了。这太疯狂了，特别是当你卖车的时候。你知道吗？又不是卖西装。
What took me a while to understand is how Jason sells so many cars, or what he's doing differently than everybody else. And we asked pretty much everybody else this question, but their answers were kind of generic. He's a good-looking kid, good personality, got the gift of the gab. Even Jason sort of defaults to truisms when you ask him what his secret is. Says he treats every customer like he would want to be treated.
我花了一段时间才理解杰森是怎么卖出这么多车的，或者他做得和别人有什么不同。我们几乎问了其他人这个问题，但他们的回答都很一般。他是个帅小伙，性格好，能说会道。当你问他秘诀时，即使是杰森也倾向于陈词滥调。说他对待每个客户就像希望被对待的那样。
But as much as you can figure out anybody in less than a week, I think Jason's success is due to three basic attributes, three characteristics he has that have propelled him to the top. So I'll go through those now.
但在不到一周内能看透任何人的情况下，我认为杰森的成功归功于三个基本属性，他拥有的三个推他到顶峰的特征。我现在就讲讲这些。
Number one, constructive delusion. Now, Jason knows that a certain percentage of customers, depending on the month, will walk away from him without buying a car. Of course that happens. And yet, paradoxically, he enters every negotiation full in the knowledge that it will not happen. As we're sitting there, he drew a picture of a very lopsided hourglass with a line across the skinny part.
第一，建设性错觉。现在，杰森知道，根据月份不同，一定比例的客户会不买车就离开他。这当然会发生。然而，自相矛盾的是，他带着它绝不会发生的信念进入每一次谈判。当我们坐在那里时，他画了一个非常不对称的沙漏，在细的地方画了一条线。
You know, are you looking at it half empty or half full? You know what I mean? Are you optimistic or are you-- what's the other word?
你是觉得它半空还是半满？你知道我在说什么吗？你是乐观主义者还是——另一个词是什么？
Pessimistic.
悲观主义者。
To Jason, the glass is not half empty, and it is not half full.
对杰森来说，杯子既不是半空，也不是半满。
Me, I'm always at 100.
我，我总是处于100%。
It is 100% full.
它是100%满的。
Yeah, it's full. And you're like, what the hell?
是的，它是满的。你会说，搞什么鬼？
No, it's not. There's only half of the water there. No, no, no.
不，不是。里面只有一半水。不，不，不。
No, it's full to me.
不，对我来说它是满的。
But for someone who barely possesses the word pessimistic in his vocabulary, that's not always how he seems on the sales floor. More than any of the other sellers, Jason's anxious.
但对于一个词汇表里几乎没有“悲观主义者”这个词的人来说，他在销售大厅看起来并不总是这样。杰森比其他销售员更焦虑。
I'm going crazy right now. I'm biting my nails. Biting my nails off because I'm stressed.
我现在快疯了。我在咬指甲。咬指甲，因为我压力很大。
Biting his nails, hovering around the manager's desk. It's like the dealership making its quota is personal to him.
咬着指甲，在经理服务台周围徘徊。就像经销店完成配额对他来说是私事一样。
Jason-- and this is number two on our list of attributes. Jason doesn't just want to sell cars. Jason needs to sell cars. Case in point, I watched him work this one deal, a lease on a Jeep Liberty. He played it totally cool at first. But when the haggling started, it was like someone had clamped a set of jumper cables to his ankle.
杰森——这是我们属性列表上的第二条。杰森不仅想卖车。杰森需要卖车。以他为例，我看着他处理这一单交易，一辆Jeep Liberty的租赁。起初他表现得完全冷静。但当讨价还价开始时，就像有人在他的脚踝上夹了一根跳线。
And between 375 and 329 is 46 times 39 is another 1,700. But you've got to put the value point on it. You now have a sunroof.
375到329之间是46，乘以39是1,700。但你必须加上价值点。你现在有了一个天窗。
The guy insists for an hour that he can't leave a deposit without talking to his wife. And then he leaves a deposit. Jason wins.
那个人坚持了一个小时，说如果不和妻子谈谈就不能留下押金。然后他留下了押金。杰森赢了。
Anthony, I really like you. I really do.
安东尼，我真的很喜欢你。我真的喜欢。
He runs outside to chat with another customer that he's already closed.
他跑出去和另一个他已经成交的客户聊天。
We're getting there.
我们快到了。
And at this point, he's completely dosed up on adrenaline, jabbering like a speed freak.
此时此刻，他完全沉浸在肾上腺素中，像个瘾君子一样喋喋不休。
I just-- I just-- I just-- I just closed one-- I just closed one that I didn't think I was going to close.
我刚才——我刚才——我刚才——我刚才成交了一笔——我刚才成交了一笔我觉得我不会成交的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. The guy was on the fence. He's like, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife, my wife. I threw something at him and he was like-- and you know those intense moments, where you're like, fuck, is he going to do it? And we did it. So exciting. It doesn't matter how many cars you do. It's like the first deal of your life.
是的。那家伙犹豫不决。他说，我老婆，我老婆，我老婆，我老婆，我老婆。我扔给他一些东西，然后他就像——你知道那些激烈的时刻，你心里说，他妈的，他会做吗？我们做到了。太兴奋了。不管你做了多少辆车。就像你生命中的第一笔交易一样。
Two hours later, he's already crashed. It's like that deal never happened.
两个小时后，他已经崩溃了。好像那笔交易从没发生过。
I'm struggling right now to get these deals out, man. I'm really strapped. I feel like I told you. I'm back on that feeling-- I'm back on that grind again. I feel like I need another 10 cars.
我现在很难把这些交易做出去，伙计。我真的很缺。我觉得我告诉过你了。我又回到了那种感觉——我又回到了那份苦差事。我觉得我还需要再卖10辆。
The high is fleeting.
快感是短暂的。
Yeah, the high's gone. I'm ready for the next dose.
是的，快感没了。我已经准备好下一剂了。
You're ready for the next one.
你已经准备好下一剂了。
Yeah.
是的。
So that's two. And then the third and final attribute that I think has led Jason to being the top seller of Town & Country, ABC. Always Be Calling your girlfriend to say, baby, I just have a couple more things to take care of and then I'll be home.
所以是两条。然后是第三条也是最后一条属性，我认为导致杰森成为Town & Country顶级销售员的原因，ABC。始终在给你女朋友打电话说，宝贝，我只需要处理几件事，然后我就回家了。
We got into an argument about it last night.
我们昨晚为此吵了一架。
Oh, no.
噢，不。
Yeah.
是的。
This is Jason's girlfriend, Gena. She stopped by to say hi to him at the shop one of the days we were there. The night before that, he had come home too late and screwed up their dinner plans. Gena says they're always running into a store five minutes before it closes. She's imposed a no-work-talk-over-dinner rule, but Jason always has just one last thing to tell her about something that happened at work.
这是杰森的女朋友吉娜。我们在那儿的那几天，她顺便来看他。前一天晚上，他回家太晚，搞砸了他们的晚餐计划。吉娜说他们总是在商店关门前五分钟跑进去。她实施了晚餐不谈工作的规则，但杰森总有最后一件关于工作发生的事要告诉她。
And they've only been together a year, so they can both still laugh about it, at least with me. But of course, working long hours can threaten everything else in your life, and the entire business of selling cars is built on working long hours, working weekends, when more customers come in, coming in on your day off, when the store needs to meet its quota. And the damage that can do is all around Jason.
他们在一起才一年，所以至少对我来说，他们还能对此一笑置之。但当然，长时间工作会威胁你生活中的一切，整个卖车生意就是建立在长时间工作、周末工作（当更多客户进来时）、在休息日来上班（当商店需要完成配额时）的基础上的。这可能造成的损害在杰森身边随处可见。
The sales guy in the cubicle next to him, Peter Possas, told me managing a sales team at a dealership in Florida is what led to his divorce.
隔壁工位的销售员彼得·波萨斯告诉我，管理佛罗里达一家经销店的销售团队是他离婚的原因。
Yeah, of course it did. I was never home. I missed all functions and stuff because I married my job.
是的，当然是。我从没回过家。我错过了所有活动之类的，因为我和我的工作结婚了。
Manny, who sits next to Peter, is separated from his wife partly due to the business. Theresa in finance said her job caused her divorce. Sal, one of the managers you heard from before, says the job was a factor in both of his divorces.
坐在彼得旁边的曼尼，由于生意部分原因与妻子分居了。财务部的特蕾莎说她的工作导致了她的离婚。你之前听过的经理之一萨尔说这份工作是他两次离婚的一个因素。
Still, Jason and Gena wouldn't even be together if it weren't for the job. They met at the dealership when she was buying from another salesperson. And now here they are, both driving the exact same kind of car.
不过，如果不是因为这份工作，杰森和吉娜甚至不会在一起。他们在经销店认识，当时她正从另一个销售员手里买车。现在他们都在开同一种车。
It's funny. We both got white Jeeps. We love them. She has a '12 I got a '14. And we just have a good time. And they're great trucks. They got everything you need, all the luxury, the right size, and they last forever.
很有趣。我们都买了白色的Jeep。我们很爱它们。她有一辆12年的，我有一辆14年的。我们玩得很开心。它们是很棒的卡车。它们拥有你需要的一切，所有的豪华，合适的尺寸，而且它们能永远开下去。
It's like you're trying to sell me now.
搞得你现在在试图卖给我一样。
Yeah. And if you've ever been-- yeah, you're going to go out and buy a car before the end of the night. You're going to be like, Ira, you know what? I'll be back at the office in about two hours. I'm picking up my new Jeep. I mean, this product is like on fire.
是的。如果你曾经——是的，你会在今晚结束前去买一辆车。你会说，艾拉，你知道吗？我大约两个小时后回到办公室。我去提我的新Jeep。我是说，这个产品太火了。
In the second half of October at Town & Country, sales stay slow. And going into the last two days of the month, they still have so many cars to sell that when Freddie sees me arrive in the morning on the next to last day of the month, knowing what it is that I'm about to ask him, he starts laughing.
在十月的下半段，Town & Country的销售依然缓慢。进入这个月的最后两天，他们还有那么多车要卖，以至于当我第二天早上到达时，知道我正要问他什么，弗雷迪开始大笑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh, boy. Here we go. We're behind 16 cars for the month so far. And that's not good. That means I need 16 cars between today and tomorrow.
哦，伙计。我们来了。我们这个月落后了16辆车。这可不好。这意味着我今天和明天之间需要16辆车。
Here's how hard that number is. Freddie tells me that he only expects 15 or 16 customers to show up in the store each day, which means that to get to his number, he's going to have to sell a car to every other person who walks in the door.
这个数字有多难呢。弗雷迪告诉我，他每天只期待15或16名客户出现在店里，这意味着为了达到他的数字，他必须卖给每个走进门的一半的人一辆车。
And what my fellow radio producers and I witness over the next two days-- OK, some deals do go through, but it's almost a catalog of all the ways that a car deal can fall apart. There were the obvious ways. A young woman doesn't get approved for her car loan. A father and son promise to come back tomorrow to sign the papers and take the car. They never come back.
而在接下来的两天里，我的广播制作人同事和我见证了——好吧，有些交易确实成功了，但这几乎是一份汽车交易可能搞砸的所有方式的目录。有显而易见的方式。一位年轻女性没有获得车贷批准。一对父子承诺第二天回来签文件提车。他们从没回来。
But there turn out to be all sorts of other ways that a car deal can implode that we had never imagined or conceived. For instance, Bob T.
但事实证明，汽车交易可能会以各种我们从未想象过或构想过的其他方式内爆。例如，鲍勃·T。
Bob, please see Rich in Finance. Bob.
鲍勃，请去找财务部的里奇。鲍勃。
You remember Bob T, the salesman with the lowest sales of anybody this month. A deal of his starts to unravel after the paperwork is signed, after the deposit is paid.
你还记得鲍勃·T，那个本月销售额最低的销售员。他的一个交易在文书工作签完、押金付完之后开始解体。
Basically, what happens is he told a couple that their new car is $2,000 cheaper than it actually is. They found out the truth while talking to Rich, the finance manager, and kind of hit the roof.
基本上，发生的事情是他告诉一对夫妇他们的新车比实际便宜2,000美元。他们在和财务经理里奇交谈时发现了真相，火冒三丈。
Why am I thinking I'm getting screwed here?
为什么我觉得我被坑了？
Bob T was also surprised. He himself thought it was $2,000 cheaper. The finance manager, Rich, tells Bob T that Bob T should have, first, better understood which rebates the couple's qualified for. That's where the mistake was. And second, he should have explained it to the couple.
鲍勃·T也很惊讶。他自己也以为便宜了2,000美元。财务经理里奇告诉鲍勃·T，鲍勃·T首先应该更好地理解这对夫妇有资格获得哪些回扣。错误就在那里。其次，他应该向这对夫妇解释清楚。
You left the middle out. You left the meat of the sandwich out.
你漏掉了中间部分。你漏掉了三明治里的肉。
That wasn't told to me. It was that we were going to give him the same discount. That's what I understood. I'm only going by the numbers that were given to me, and I gave him the numbers, and he signed it. It started with $28,960.
没人告诉我那个。这就是说我们将给他们同样的折扣。我是这么理解的。我只是照着给我的数字去做，我给了他们数字，他签了名。它从28,960美元开始。
Rich manages to save this deal, but barely.
里奇成功地挽救了这笔交易，但非常勉强。
THEN AROUND 7: 00 at night on the next-to-last day of the month, one of the salesmen, Scott Froehlich, gets some weird news about one of his sales. He tells one of our producers, Jonathan Menjivar, that some customers that he had just sold a car to were now coming back to the dealership, but not to pick up their new car and take it home. No, no, no.
然后在该月的倒数第二天晚上7点左右，销售员之一斯科蒂·弗罗利希收到了一些关于他销售的奇怪消息。他告诉我们的制作人乔纳森·门吉瓦尔，一些他刚卖出一辆车的客户现在要回到经销店，但不是为了提走他们的新车回家。不，不，不。
They have to pick out another car because the other car was sold and nobody marked it.
他们必须挑选另一辆车，因为另一辆车被卖了，没人做记号。
It was sold?
它被卖了？
Yep.
是的。
That's right. They accidentally sold the same car twice to two different customers.
没错。他们不小心把同一辆车卖给了两个不同的客户。
Here's how it happened. Scott had sold a red Jeep Grand Cherokee to this customer, this guy who came in with his dad. They left a deposit. But another salesman, Mike Lester-- everybody calls him Mike L-- had already sold that same car the day before. The customer hadn't picked up the car yet. And the little magnetic chip that they use to keep track of the sales, the one for this car, nobody had put it on the whiteboard in Freddie's office, the board that keeps track of who sold what. Scott is not happy.
事情是这样发生的。斯科蒂把一辆红色Jeep大切诺基卖给了这个客户，那个和他父亲一起来的家伙。他们留下了押金。但另一个销售员，迈克·莱斯特——大家都叫他迈克·L——在前一天已经卖掉了那辆车。客户还没来提车。他们用来追踪销售的小磁筹码，那辆车的筹码，没人把它放在弗雷迪办公室的白板上，那块记录谁卖了什么的板子上。斯科蒂很不高兴。
I want a drink. You're welcome to come over for a fucking drink.
我想喝一杯。欢迎过来喝一杯。
Or maybe this does a better job capturing his mood.
或者也许这能更好地捕捉他的情绪。
God, I want to shoot myself right now.
天哪，我现在想自杀。
An hour later, the customer is back on the lot with his dad, and Scott walks up to him. And maybe this is the time to tell you that Scott moonlights as a mortician, which means he's used to handling all kinds of situations with customers. And so even though he did absolutely nothing wrong, here's what he says.
一个小时后，客户和他父亲回到了店里，斯科蒂向他走去。也许现在是时候告诉你，斯科蒂在兼职做殡葬承办人，这意味着他习惯处理各种与客户的情况。所以即使他绝对没做错任何事，这就是他说的话。
I fucked up and I sold a sold car.
我搞砸了，我卖了一辆已经卖出的车。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'll admit it.
我承认。
Broke my heart, Fredo. Broke my heart.
心都碎了，弗雷多。心都碎了。
Hope you got the customer's Godfather reference there.
希望你听懂了客户对《教父》的引用。
Scott tells him that if the other sale falls through, the car is his. But the other deal does not fall through, so Scott and the guy go wandering around the lot in the dark, looking for another Grand Cherokee-- red. The guy is set on red. And they find one.
斯科蒂告诉他，如果另一笔交易搞砸了，车就是他的。但另一笔交易没搞砸，所以斯科蒂和那家伙在黑暗中围着停车场游荡，寻找另一辆大切诺基——红色的。那家伙非红色不可。他们找到了一辆。
What is this one?
这一辆是什么？
Yes, it is another red Grand Cherokee. Scott writes down the stock number, runs to the desk to check it out, and it has also been sold. Scott's only hope is that that deal will fall apart and he can sell the car to this customer, who he sends home. Fingers crossed.
是的，这是另一辆红色大切诺基。斯科蒂记下库存编号，跑到服务台去查，结果它也卖掉了。斯科蒂唯一的希望是那笔交易会搞砸，他可以把车卖给这位他已经送回家的客户。祈祷吧。
The night, however, is still not over. Then around quarter to 8:00 that night, something happens at the desk that really, really ticks off the manager, Sal.
然而，那个夜晚还没结束。然后在那天晚上8点差一刻左右，服务台发生了一件事，真的、真的让经理萨尔非常恼火。
The amount of stupidity that just happened far exceeds anything I have ever experienced in the car business.
刚才发生的愚蠢行为远超我在汽车行业经历过的任何事情。
OK, here's the short version. Stephen Brown, a computer engineer from New Jersey, has come in to finalize a deal on a new Dodge Challenger coupe. Sal greets him.
好的，简短版本。来自新泽西的计算机工程师斯蒂芬·布朗进来敲定一辆新道奇挑战者轿跑车的交易。萨尔迎接他。
How you doing?
你好吗？
I'm all right.
我很好。
Stephen is Lori's customer, the one woman on the sales team. But Lori is out sick. Stephen tells Sal that she texted him that somebody else was going to be taking care of the deal.
斯蒂芬是洛丽的客户，销售团队里唯一的女性。但洛丽病了。斯蒂芬告诉萨尔，她发短信说会有别人来处理这笔交易。
She didn't tell you who?
她没告诉你谁？
No. She just texted a message about--
没有。她只是发了一条关于——的消息。
All right, Give me a few minutes. If you want, you can grab a seat in the waiting area over there.
好了，给我几分钟。如果你愿意，可以在那边的等候区找个位子。
Stephen sits down. Sal gets Lori on the phone.
斯蒂芬坐下。萨尔给洛丽打电话。
I have a customer of yours here says someone else is supposed take care of him. Who's supposed to take care of him? All right, good. Mike Lester's gone for the night. So now what do I do? Well, he's gone, too.
我这儿有你的一位客户，说应该有别人来处理他。该谁处理他？好了，好的。迈克·莱斯特今晚走了。那我该怎么办？好吧，他也走了。
Sal pages Scotty, but he's not around. Peter's around, but he's working another deal. Then, you know how in every shop of every kind everywhere there is that one team-playing, late-staying, extra go-gettery kid you can turn to who will always help clean up whatever weirdo mess just erupted one hour before closing? Yeah. In this case, that would happen to be--
萨尔传呼斯科蒂，但他不在。彼得在，但他正在处理另一笔交易。然后，你知道无论在哪里的任何商店，总会有那种你可以求助的、有团队精神、留到最后、额外积极的家伙，无论什么时候，一小时前刚爆发的奇怪混乱，他总能帮忙清理？是的。在这种情况下，那恰好是——
Jason, what are you doing right now?
杰森，你现在在干什么？
Jason comes over to the podium. Sean Cole, who is trailing Jason, picks up the story from here.
杰森来到讲台。正在跟随杰森的肖恩·科尔从这里接过了故事。
So Jason comes over to the desk, and Sal explains what's going on.
所以杰森来到服务台，萨尔解释了正在发生的事情。
Here's the rundown. You ready? This is Lori's customer. The customer came in to see Lori. Lori's not here today, so she set it up with Mike Lester. Mike Lester went home. Mike Perez knew about the deal. Mike Perez went home. TK's a finance manager on the deal. He's off today. So now I'm supposed to piece this together.
这是摘要。准备好了吗？这是洛丽的客户。客户来看洛丽。洛丽今天不在这，所以她和迈克·莱斯特安排好了。迈克·莱斯特回家了。迈克·佩雷斯知道这笔交易。迈克·佩雷斯回家了。TK是这笔交易的财务经理。他今天休息。所以现在我要拼凑这个。
What are we doing?
我们在做什么？
I'm not quite clear.
我不清楚。
Is the thing billed out?
东西记账了吗？
I'm not quite clear.
我不清楚。
OK. So what am I doing right now?
OK。那我现在在干什么？
It's not quite clear.
不太清楚。
He's not quite clear.
他不太清楚。
I know the call was ready last-- how you doing, sir?
我知道电话在那时准备好了——你好吗，先生？
Good. I'm Jason.
好。我是杰森。
Now, this isn't a situation where Stephen just needs to sign some papers and pick up the keys to his new car. There are still a lot of steps to march through.
现在，这不是斯蒂芬只需要签些文件拿走新车钥匙的情况。还有很多步骤要走。
(WHISPERING) I have other things to do.
（低语）我还有其他事情要做。
He finds the folder and learns that Stephen and Lori never got to a final final offer for his trade-in. In order to do that, the car has to go up on the lift for a full inspection in the service department, which is inexplicably closed on this, the second-to-last day of the month, when they need absolutely every sale they can get.
他找到文件夹，了解到斯蒂芬和洛丽从来没对他的旧车抵价达成最后的最终报价。为了做到这一点，车必须放在升降机上在维修部进行全面检查，而那个维修部在此月的倒数第二天（他们需要每一笔销售的时候）莫名其妙地关闭了。
They didn't call me to see if they could leave. We're going to lose this deal.
他们没打电话给我看他们能否离开。我们会失去这笔交易。
With no inspection, there's no trade-in. And with no trade-in, there's no deal. Somebody finally does a cursory inspection on the car, without the lift, in the dark.
没有检查就没有以旧换新。没有以旧换新就没有交易。有人终于在黑暗中，不用升降机对车进行了粗略检查。
All the while, Stephen is getting more and more anxious that no one seems to know what's going on. Jason tries to get him in with the finance guy to work out the terms of the deal, but the finance guy's busy. Jason explains this to Sal, which sets Sal off again.
一直以来，斯蒂芬越来越焦虑，因为没人知道发生了什么。杰森试图让他去财务部敲定交易条款，但财务员很忙。杰森向萨尔解释了这一点，这再次让萨尔爆发了。
He needs to sit with that customer. This is a--
他需要和那个客户坐在一起。这是一个——
No, don't worry. Don't get excited. Don't get excited.
不，别担心。别激动。别激动。
Dude, I'm about ready to walk the fuck out.
伙计，我快要走了。
No, don't get--
不，别——
Like, no bullshit.
没有废话。
No, don't get excited.
不，别激动。
OK? I've never been in a store this fucked up in my life.
OK？我这辈子从没在一家乱成这样的店里呆过。
Don't get excited. I don't want you to get excited. I want you to just remain calm.
别激动。我不想让你激动。我只想让你保持冷静。
This is actually the third time Stephen's made the trek out here from New Jersey. It's a two-hour drive he does not want to make again.
这其实是斯蒂芬第三次从新泽西跑出来。这是他不想再做的两个小时车程。
I love the car, but if they don't get--
我喜欢这辆车，但如果他们不——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They're going to have to get it done.
他们必须把它完成。
They cannot lose this deal. They're still 10 cars short of their monthly goal. When Stephen does sit down with the finance manager, he can't get the interest rate he wanted, 3.3%. They finally resolve that, but then he doesn't have insurance for the new vehicle, or he hasn't called Geico to transfer the policy from his old car, and he takes care of that, too.
他们不能失去这笔交易。他们距离每月目标还差10辆车。当斯蒂芬坐下来和财务经理谈时，他没能得到他想要的3.3%利率。他们终于解决了那个，但然后他没有新车的保险，或者他还没打过电话给Geico把保单从旧车上转过来，他也处理了那个。
But then, as he's transferring his stuff from the trunk of his old car into the new one, the billing office notices a glitch. Something's wrong with the new insurance card from Geico. Stephen's address isn't on it. And the date on it says October 31, even though it's October 30. That means Stephen won't be able to legally drive the car until the following day.
但然后，当他把东西从旧车的后备箱转到新车里时，结算办公室注意到一个毛病。Geico的新保险卡有点问题。上面没有斯蒂芬的地址。而且上面的日期写着10月31日，尽管今天是10月30日。这意味着斯蒂芬要等到第二天才能合法驾驶这辆车。
Tiffany, good aft-- good evening. This is Jason. I'm a sales representative at Town & Country Jeep.
蒂芙尼，下午好——晚上好。我是杰森。我是Town & Country Jeep的销售代表。
Jason gets on the phone with Geico, thinking maybe it'll be an easy fix. It won't be. We all stand around and watch him work this thing.
杰森打给Geico，心想这可能很容易修正。其实不然。我们都站在周围看他处理这件事。
I'm sitting with a client of yours, and he's purchasing a vehicle, picking it up tonight. I have the ID card.
我和你的客户坐在一起，他正在买车，今晚提车。我有身份证件。
It's quarter past 10:00 at this point.
此时已经是10点15分。
But it's not like he's opening up a new policy. So what are we doing here?
但这不是像他开启新保单。所以我们在做什么？
Then it's 10:26.
然后是10点26分。
Well, we've got to try to make an exception, if you can. Please talk to your supervisor one more time, if you can.
好吧，我们必须试着破例，如果可以的话。请再和你的主管谈谈，如果可以的话。
Finally, Tiffany comes through.
最后，蒂芙尼做到了。
Oh, my god, you're the best.
噢，天哪，你是最棒的。
Geico says it'll email a new insurance card. Jason keeps Tiffany, the operator, on the line until everything is squared away with the billing office.
Geico说会电邮一张新的保险卡。杰森让蒂芙尼（操作员）留在在线，直到一切与结算办公室核实清楚。
How long you been working for Geico? You sound like you really got a lot of enthusiasm for what you do.
你在Geico工作多久了？你听起来对所做的事情真的很有热情。
(LAUGHING) Thank you.
（笑着）谢谢。
Billing gives the all clear. We all follow Stephen out to the parking lot. It's about 11 o'clock at this point. Jason giddily watches him tear out of the parking lot and hang a right.
结算办公室放行了。我们都跟着斯蒂芬来到停车场。此时大约是11点。杰森兴高采烈地看着他撕开停车场，向右转。
Jersey's that way! He went east. Jersey's west. Oh, my goodness.
泽西在那边！他往东去了。泽西在西边。噢，天哪。
Well, coming up, car talk continues. That feels really weird to say. But it's true. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
好了，接下来，汽车谈话继续。说这话感觉真奇怪。但这是真的。那是在从芝加哥公共广播电台接下来的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program is a rerun. We did all the reporting for today's show a few years ago during a month, October 2013, when car sales were strong, up over 10% what they were a year before around the country. That's 1.2 million new vehicles sold that month. But that doesn't mean that every dealership in every town had an easy time of it.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是重播。我们为今天的节目所做的所有报道都是在几年前，2013年10月，当时汽车销售强劲，比一年前全国增长了10%以上。那是当月售出的120万辆新车。但这并不意味着每个城镇的每家经销店都过得很轻松。
And today on our program, we watch one dealership, just one, on Long Island-- Town & Country Jeep Chrysler Dodge Ram is what it's called-- as they try to make their sales goal of 129 cars for the month. If they sell 129 cars, Chrysler is going to pay them a big bonus, and they need that money to be in the black for the month. If they just sell 128, bupkis.
今天在我们的节目中，我们看着一家经销店，仅仅一家，在长岛——叫Town & Country Jeep Chrysler Dodge Ram——因为他们试图达成129辆车的月销售目标。如果他们卖掉129辆车，克莱斯勒会支付他们一笔大额奖金，他们需要那笔钱来在该月盈利，而不是亏损。如果只卖128辆，什么都没有。
So it's 9:15 in the morning on the 31st. How many cars do you got to get?
所以现在是31号早上9点15分。你还得卖多少辆车？
Nine.
9辆。
That's Freddie, the general manager here.
那是弗雷迪，这里的总经理。
Nine more.
再卖9辆。
And what do you have to say about that?
对此你有什么要说的吗？
God help us.
上帝保佑我们。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
God help us. I don't know. It's going to be-- it's going to be hard.
上帝保佑我们。我不知道。这会是——这会很难。
On a good month, he would start the last day with just two or three cars to sell. Nine. That's crazy. And it's Halloween, which means that lots of potential customers are going to be out with their kids today.
在好的月份，他会在最后一天开始时只需要卖两三辆车。9辆。这太疯狂了。而且今天是万圣节，这意味着今天会有很多潜在客户和孩子们在一起。
Everybody is so tense that it's not even 10:00 in the morning and a customer walks out without buying a car.
每个人都太紧张了，甚至还不到早上10点，一个客户没买车就走了。
No, we're done. Sorry, but we're done. I came in to make a deal, and that's not what I was expecting.
不，我们完了。抱歉，但我们完了。我进来是为了达成交易，但这并不是我所期待的。
Thank you. Have a good night.
谢谢。晚安。
And one of the managers, Sal, has this edgy little conversation with the salesman who let him walk out.
其中一位经理萨尔，和那个让他走掉的销售员进行了这次紧张的小对话。
What happened to that guy you were working?
那个你正在处理的家伙怎么了？
He left.
他走了。
You've got to stop doing that, bro.
你必须停止那样做，兄弟。
How do I stop doing that? You don't help. You got a meeting--
我怎么停止那样做？你没帮忙。你有一个会议——
You didn't even come up here. How am I supposed to help? Where's my crystal ball, in the shop? Do it again, you're following him.
你甚至没上来。我怎么帮你？我的水晶球在哪，在店里吗？再做一次，你跟着他走。
Let's do it. Let's do it right now.
我们做吧。我们现在就做。
Go ahead. Pack up. Go.
继续。收拾行李。走。
He doesn't go.
他没走。
Un-fucking-real.
真他妈的不真实。
The morning's still young when I find Freddie in his office selling a car to himself-- a loaner car for the maintenance department to lend out to customers who are getting their cars repaired. He's allowed to count that in his sales total.
早上还早的时候，我发现弗雷迪在办公室里卖车给自己——一辆给维护部门借给正在维修车辆的客户的备用车。他被允许将此计入他的销售总额中。
So now we only need eight more. See, it's starting to come together already.
所以现在我们只需要再卖8辆。你看，它已经开始成形了。
By mid-afternoon, he'll buy a second loaner car for the dealership. Back in February, Freddie bought a Durango for his wife to make the number that month, replacing a car that he had just bought a year before for her for the same reason.
到下午，他会为经销店买第二辆备用车。早在二月，弗雷迪为妻子买了一辆Durango以达到那个月的数字，更换了他一年前为了同样原因刚买给她的车。
Joe? What's the story with your cars?
乔？你的车是怎么回事？
Freddie is calling Joe Monti, one of the guys who runs the used car side of the business at Town & Country. Joe has got his own goal to hit for the month that is separate from the new car goal. 70 used cars. That's the number Freddie set for him.
弗雷迪在给乔·蒙蒂打电话，负责Town & Country二手车业务的家伙之一。乔有自己的月度目标要达到，与新车目标分开。70辆二手车。那是弗雷迪给他设定的数字。
Is any of them going out yet or what? What are we doing?
它们出去了一辆吗还是怎样？我们在做什么？
They're all going out, boss.
它们都出去了，老板。
OK, but how come none was even delivered yet? I'm still sitting at six.
好的，但为什么一辆都没交付？我还坐在6辆上。
Yuri's delivered the Chevy Trailblazer.
尤里交付了雪佛兰开拓者。
Hold on. What?
等等。什么？
While we were at Town & Country, we asked everybody what it would mean for him or her personally if the team did not make its sales goal. And it was actually this guy, Joe Monti, over in used cars, who gave us the best picture of that. Sarah Koenig hung out with him for a while.
在Town & Country时，我们问每个人，如果团队没达成销售目标，对他个人意味着什么。事实上是这个家伙，二手车的乔·蒙蒂，给了我们最好的写照。莎拉·柯尼格和他呆了一段时间。
Joe's particularly stressed out this month. Half the time I'm with him, it feels like he's fighting, even with customers.
乔这个月特别紧张。我陪他的一半时间里，感觉他都在抗争，甚至是对抗客户。
Nobody's giving you a runaround, Jessica, OK? Yelling and screaming and being rude and threatening is not going to get you anywhere. The car-- the car-- the car is a great car.
没人给你设圈套，杰西卡，OK？大喊大叫、粗鲁无礼和威胁是不会有用的。这辆车——这辆车——这辆车是一辆好车。
Next fight, he calls a woman in the back office who he thinks ratted to Freddie about a deal she didn't like.
下一次争吵，他给后台的一位女士打电话，他认为她向弗雷迪举报了一笔她不喜欢的交易。
Theresa? Well, can you pick up the phone? Nails could get done later. Why did you run-- why did you run to Freddie? Why did you run to Freddie and tell Freddie about a Chrysler 300? Whose conversation? Why were you talking to Eddie? First of all, if a manager writes off on a deal and signs it-- she hung up the phone.
特蕾莎？好吧，你能接电话吗？指甲以后再弄。你为什么跑——你为什么跑去弗雷迪那里？你为什么跑去弗雷迪那里，告诉弗雷迪关于一辆克莱斯勒300的事？谁的谈话？你为什么和埃迪谈？首先，如果经理批准了一笔交易并签了字——她挂了电话。
I'm sort of surprised anyone would have the balls to fight with Joe. He's a big man-- 350 pounds. Large and in charge. The day I meet him, he's wearing a gray tracksuit,
我有点惊讶竟然有人有胆量和乔吵架。他是个大块头——350磅。庞大且负责。我见他的那天，他穿着灰色运动服，
but what I quickly find out is that he's wearing a tracksuit because it's his day off. He's supposed to be at his son Mike's football game against Malvern. He hasn't been able to catch an away game all season, and he took this one Sunday off to do it. It was important to him.
但我很快发现他穿运动服是因为那是他的休息日。他本应去参加他儿子迈克对抗马尔文的足球比赛。整个赛季他都没能赶上一场客场比赛，而他请了这个周日休息去参加。这对他很重要。
For so many years, he wasn't around enough for his kids. He's working all the time. Joe knows Mike will be looking for him in the stands right about now. And he's not going to be there because he's here at the car lot.
多年来，他陪伴孩子的时间不够。他总是整天工作。乔知道迈克现在就在看台上找他。而他不会在那里，因为他在汽车地段。
We're a little shorthanded, so I've got to be here, which is not a problem. Listen, if I'm making money, I'm making money. Just it's a catch-22. You're missing a game, but that's the car business.
我们人手有点不足，所以我必须在这里，这不是问题。听着，如果我在赚钱，我就是在赚钱。只是这是一个两难境地。你错过了一场比赛，但这就是汽车生意。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's the car business. I'll make it up to him later.
这就是汽车生意。我以后会补偿他的。
Yesterday, Joe was late to his mother-in-law's surprise 70th birthday party. And last week, he was late for his own mother's 60th. The used car side of Town & Country is supposed to sell 70 cars by the end of the month. That's Joe's version of the 129 on the new side.
昨天，乔去参加他岳母的70岁惊喜生日派对迟到了。上周，他参加他自己母亲的60岁生日也迟到了。Town & Country的二手车方被要求在月底前卖出70辆车。那是乔对新车方129辆的那个版本。
When I first met Joe, used was at 35. At stake is Joe's big year-end bonus. Joe wouldn't tell me the amount of the bonus, but he made it clear it's very, very nice. Down-payment-on-a-house nice.
当我第一次见到乔时，二手车是35辆。赌注是乔的大额年终奖金。乔没告诉我奖金数额，但他明确表示这非常、非常好。能在房子上付首付的那种好。
Since he fell so behind the last couple months, this month, October, is make or break for Joe. He's got to get to at least 70 cars if he wants any hope of reaching that bonus by the end of the year. And it's not looking good. 20 years in the business, Joe's never seen a stretch this slow for this long.
因为过去几个月他落后太多，这个月，十月，对乔来说是成败在此一举。如果他想在年底前有任何希望获得那笔奖金，他必须达到至少70辆车。而且情况看起来不好。在这个行业干了20年，乔从未见过这么慢、这么久的一段时期。
Joe blames it mostly on Hurricane Sandy. A year ago, tens of thousands of people lost their cars all at once. And they got new ones all at once. So now, a year later, tens of thousands of people are out of the used car market who normally would be buying and selling right now.
乔主要把这归咎于飓风桑迪。一年前，成千上万的人同时失去了他们的车。他们同时得到了新车。所以现在，一年后，成千上万的人退出了二手车市场，而他们本该在此时买卖的。
We had two weekends in a row we sold one car.
我们连续两个周末只卖了一辆车。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
For two Saturdays and two Sundays, and we sold one car.
两个周六和两个周日，我们只卖了一辆车。
In the whole weekend?
整个周末？
The whole weekend. The whole two weekends, we sold one car. There was days we didn't see a customer.
整个周末。那两个完整的周末，我们卖了一辆车。甚至有几天我们没见到一个客户。
Joe goes outside to do an appraisal on a Nissan Quest. This also gives him a chance to have a cigarette, one of about 40 Parliaments he'll smoke today. His wife and kids get on him about the smoking. He's got six kids. Six kids-- two are grown, four of them still at home.
乔出去评估一辆日产Quest。这也让他有机会抽支烟，他今天会抽的约40支Parliament之一。他的妻子和孩子们因为吸烟而纠缠他。他有六个孩子。六个孩子——两个长大了，四个还在家里。
Joe's the only breadwinner in the family-- always has been-- so it's all on him. Even in the best of times, Joe's a worrier, like his grandmother. He's 42 years old, but he looks older. In the past year, he's gained about 80 pounds.
乔是家里唯一的经济支柱——一直都是——所以压力全在他身上。即使在最好的时候，乔也是个忧虑者，像他祖母一样。他42岁，但看起来更老。在过去的一年里，他胖了约80磅。
In the parking lot, Joe throws away a half-smoked cigarette and then looks over the Nissan Quest. Tires are so-so. Needs some detailing. It's got a cracked taillight and a bad CARFAX report, meaning it's been in an accident. $2,000 is fair for this car, Joe says. It's what these are going for at auction.
在停车场，乔扔掉了一支抽了一半的烟，然后检查那辆日产Quest。轮胎一般。需要做些细节处理。它有一个裂开的尾灯和一份糟糕的CARFAX报告，意味着它发生过事故。这辆车2,000美元很公道，乔说。这是它们在拍卖会上的价格。
He tells me the customers are going to want at least $2,500, but there's no way he can do that. $2,500 is just too much. He heads back inside.
他告诉我客户至少会想要2,500美元，但他绝对做不到。2,500美元太多了。他走回里面。
$2,500, that's everything.
2,500美元，那可是全部了。
Instantly caves.
瞬间屈服。
That's what I will do.
这就是我会做的。
He needs the deal. They shake on it.
他需要这笔交易。他们握手成交。
Joe was about 22 when he started in the car business. He had a baby at 18-- his son, Joseph-- and then four more kids-- Dean, Chris, Michael, and Adriana, plus his stepson, Louis.
乔大约22岁时开始进入汽车行业。他在18岁时就有了孩子——他的儿子，约瑟夫——然后又是四个孩子——迪恩、克里斯、迈克尔和阿德里安娜，加上他的继子路易斯。
Joe himself was one of five kids. His mom raised them by herself, no dad around, no money. He moved around a lot. With his own kids, he's the uptight parent, the one who doesn't laugh enough, the one who hammers them about consequences. He wants his kids to fear his wrath but also to know he loves them. Sometimes, it's tricky for him to balance that or even to talk about it.
乔自己是五个孩子之一。他妈妈独自抚养他们，没有父亲在场，没钱。他搬了很多次家。对他自己的孩子，他是那个紧张的家长，那个笑得不够多、那个猛烈抨击他们后果的家长。他希望他的孩子敬畏他的愤怒，但也知道他爱他们。有时，对他来说平衡这一点，甚至谈论它都很棘手。
I have a good relationship with my children. I didn't have a father. So it's hard to do something when you don't know how to do it. Sometimes you don't know how to do-- I'm like a manly man.
我和我的孩子们关系很好。我没有父亲。所以当你不知道怎么做时，做某事很难。有时你不知道该怎么做——我像一个硬汉。
So I love them very much, but I don't know how to sometimes show it to them. I kiss them. I hug them. But you know what I'm saying? Something that I have to adapt to. But that's it. They're good. They're good kids.
所以我非常爱他们，但我有时不知道怎么向他们展示。我亲吻他们。我拥抱他们。但你知道我在说什么吗？这是我必须适应的事情。但就这样。他们很好。他们是好孩子。
Joe wants his kids to have more stability than he had growing up and a better standard of living. For 16 years, they all lived in a big house in Smithtown in a fairly wealthy neighborhood. And Joe says there was pressure there. Some other kids at school had fancy clothes and extravagant vacations, blow-out sweet 16 parties. He didn't want his kids to feel less-than, so he made sure, within reason, that they had what the other kids had.
乔希望他的孩子拥有比他成长时期更多的稳定性，更好的生活水平。16年来，他们都住在史密斯镇一个相当富裕的社区的一栋大房子里。乔说那里有压力。学校里有些其他孩子有漂亮的衣服和奢侈的假期，挥霍的16岁生日派对。他不想让他的孩子感到不如人，所以他确保在合理范围内，他们拥有其他孩子所拥有的一切。
But three years ago, he left Town & Country for another job at a Toyota dealer, and it didn't go well at all. He lost-- well, he says he lost everything. But in any case, it was a lot of money. They sold their big house in Smithtown and moved to a smaller house in Levittown, about five minutes from the dealership. And in a lot of ways, Joe's glad about that. It's made them closer as a family, he says.
但三年前，他为了另一份工作离开Town & Country去了丰田经销商，结果完全不顺。他失去了——好吧，他说他失去了一切。但无论如何，那是很多钱。他们卖掉了史密斯镇的大房子，搬到了莱维敦的一栋小房子里，距离经销店约五分钟路程。而在很多方面，乔对此很高兴。他说这让他们作为一个家庭更亲密了。
But he's also trying to work his way back up. He'd like to be able to buy them all a bigger house, give everyone a little more room. That's why he's so worried about this bad stretch of business and about getting that bonus.
但他也在努力往上爬。他希望能给他们买一栋更大的房子，给每个人多一点空间。这就是为什么他如此担心这段糟糕的生意，以及那笔奖金。
Toward the end of the day, his son Mike calls. Joe's already spoken to the coach about how the football game went.
接近一天结束时，他儿子迈克打来电话。乔已经和教练谈过足球比赛的情况了。
Two sacks and two tackles. That's great.
两次擒杀和两次扑击。那太棒了。
OK. Wait, Dad.
OK。等等，爸爸。
What?
什么？
Do you think [INAUDIBLE] to your job so you can give us some money so we can go get something to eat?
你觉得[听不清]到你的工作，这样你就可以给我们一些钱，我们可以去买点吃的吗？
Yeah. All right. I'll be home in probably, hopefully, like 20 minutes, and I'll give you money to go out to eat.
是的。好的。我大约——希望如此——20分钟后回家，我会给你钱出去吃饭。
OK. [INAUDIBLE].
OK。[听不清]。
All right. Bye.
好的。拜。
Every one of them. And it's hard to say no. You try your best. When you're doing well, it's no big deal, and you can take care of them. And then there's just doing well to where you're making it by.
每一个都是这样。很难说不。你尽你所能。当你做得好的时候，没大不了，你可以照顾他们。然后就是做得刚好维持生计的时候。
What is it? Today's October. What's going to happen in a couple of months when my son's get ready to leave for college? Am I going to have the money?
这是什么？今天是十月。几个月后我儿子准备去上大学时会发生什么？我会有钱吗？
It's mid-afternoon on the new car side of Town & Country. So what do you do all day on the last day of the month when you need to sell everything you possibly can? Well, instead of waiting for customers to come into the store, you call up any lead you have and try to close deals right over the phone if you can.
那是Town & Country新车方下午。那么在月底最后一天，当你需要尽可能多地卖掉所有东西时，你整天做什么？好吧，与其等待客户走进店里，你打给任何你有的潜在客户，如果可以，就在电话里谈成交易。
One of the salespeople, Lori, does this with a previous customer. Jason also sells to a guy he knows over the phone. Peter gets a lead from a cop upstate that he sold a Durango truck to. The lead is a friend of the cop's, also a cop, who wants the same deal his friend got. Peter gets him on the phone and says he'll give him the deal for two reasons.
其中一位销售员，洛丽，和一个之前的客户这么做了。杰森也通过电话卖给了一个他认识的家伙。彼得从一位住在外地的警察那里得到了一个潜在客户，他曾卖给那警察一辆Durango卡车。那个潜在客户是那警察的朋友，也是位警察，想要和他朋友一样的交易。彼得在电话里和他谈，说他会给他那个交易，有两个原因。
One of them, you were referred. And the other one is you're an officer of the law, and we respect that over here, big time, just so you know.
其中一个，你被推荐了。另一个是你是一位法律官员，我们在这里非常尊重这一点，只是让你知道。
Of course, this leaves out the third and main reason for the great deal that he's getting-- they need eight more sales by 9 o'clock. And the cop ends up buying his Durango for $2,214 less than the dealership paid for it. Even after finance charges and holdback and all the other ways they make money, they still lost on this one.
当然，这忽略了他得到的那个伟大交易的第三个也是主要原因——他们在9点前还需要8辆销售额。而那位警察最终买下的Durango比经销店付出的价格少了2,214美元。即使在财务费用、留存和他们赚钱的其他方式之后，他们在这个项目上仍然亏损。
Ditto this guy, Richard Massana. He was going to get an oil change this morning and stepped in on a whim and they showed him numbers way lower than any other dealer that he'd been to. Richard called up his wife to let her know, hey, surprise, we're getting a new truck. On his test drive, he still seemed amazed at what was happening.
理查德·马萨纳这家伙也是如此。他本来早上要换油，一时兴起进来了，他们向他展示了比他去过的任何其他经销商都低得多的数字。理查德打电话给他的妻子，让她知道，嘿，惊喜，我们要买一辆新卡车。在试驾时，他似乎对他所经历的一切感到惊讶。
Who would have thought Halloween, buying a truck? I never thought it would happen.
谁会想到万圣节买卡车？我从没想过会发生。
His payment will be $425 a month. The salesman says later that it should have been $525, but it's the end of the month. Turns out, yes, it is true that you do get a better deal at the end of the month at Town & Country-- at least any month that they're struggling to make their goal.
他的月供是425美元。销售员后来表示本来应该是525美元，但这是月底。结果证明，是的，确实没错，在Town & Country月底确实能得到更好的交易——至少在他们努力达成目标的任何月份。
When you actually look at the numbers, the cars that they sell on the last two days, the average deal actually loses money versus the deals that they make at the beginning of the month, where they made about $900 per car. OK, for car people, I'm now going to say these words. I am factoring in everything they made on financing and warranties and extras and holdback and the 1% they get from Chrysler on every car when I make that statement.
当你真正查看数字时，他们在最后两天卖出的车，平均交易实际上是在亏钱，对比他们在月初做的交易（每辆车大约赚900美元）。好的，对于汽车人，我现在要说这些话。我在做那个陈述时，把他们在融资、保修、额外项目上赚的所有钱，以及克莱斯勒给的1%留存都计算在内了。
I am not factoring in any money that they would get if they hit their number and get their bonus from Chrysler. That would add about $500 per car, which still does not give them a huge profit per car. It used to be a lot higher. But today, because people research prices on the internet, profit margins on new cars are lower than what they used to be, not just here at this dealership, but everywhere in the car business.
我没有把如果他们达到数字并从克莱斯勒获得奖金时他们可能得到的任何钱计算在内。那会给每辆车增加大约500美元，这仍然不能给他们每辆车带来巨大的利润。它曾经高得多。但今天，因为人们在互联网上研究价格，新车的利润率比以前低了，不仅是在这家店，在整个汽车行业都是如此。
The owner of Town & Country told me that he used to make $500 more per car, and each salesman made more per car. Now they all have to make it up in volume. So it's more of a grind, a harder job with tighter deals and less reward.
Town & Country的老板告诉我，他每辆车曾经多赚500美元，每个销售员每辆车也赚得更多。现在他们必须通过成交量来弥补。所以这更像是一种苦差事，一份利润更薄、交易更紧、回报更少的工作。
And if you're wondering, car dealerships make less profit than other businesses. A recent study by an outfit called Sageworks found that car dealers end up with less than $0.03 on every dollar they make as profit, which is less profit than furniture stores, office supply stores, restaurants. Lower than pretty much everything but grocery stores. When car dealers say that they are not making a killing, on average, it's true.
如果你感到好奇，汽车经销店的利润比其他企业少。Sageworks最近的一项研究发现，汽车经销商每赚1美元作为利润的不到0.03美元，这比家具店、办公用品店、餐馆的利润都少。比几乎所有东西都低，除了杂货店。当汽车经销商说他们平均没有在大捞一笔时，这是真的。
At some point during this last day of the month, one of the deals that they had been counting on falls through. Mike Lester's sale of a red Grand Cherokee. But turns out that's no problem for the dealership because Scott has a customer who wants that exact same truck. You remember that deal the day before, where two salesmen sold the same car to two different customers. The mortician? It's that salesman and that customer, and the salesman, Scott, is very, very happy. And the only bad news about all of this is what it does to Mike Lester's sales total for the month.
在本月最后一天期间的某个时刻，他们一直指望的一笔交易搞砸了。迈克·莱斯特卖出一辆红色大切诺基。但结果这对经销店来说没问题，因为斯科蒂有一个客户想要那辆同样的卡车。你记得前一天的那个交易吗，两个销售员把同一辆车卖给了两个不同的客户。那个殡葬承办人？就是那个销售员和那个客户，而销售员斯科蒂，非常、非常高兴。而所有这一切的唯一坏消息是它对迈克·莱斯特当月销售总额的影响。
That drops me down to 14.
这把我降到了14。
14 sucks because, like I said earlier, 15 is the magic number. 15 is where the serious bonuses and commissions kick in. Most of the guys count on getting those.
14很糟糕，因为，正如我之前所说，15是神奇数字。15是严重奖金和佣金生效的地方。大多数家伙指望获得那些。
It could add up to big money.
它可能加起来是一大笔钱。
But then, Scott, whose customer is now going to get the red Grand Cherokee, Scott realizes what this means for Mike and says to Mike--
但然后，斯科蒂，那位客户现在要得到红色大切诺基的家伙，斯科蒂意识到这对迈克意味着什么，并对迈克说——
Wait, is that your 15th car?
等等，那是你的第15辆车吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You take the chip. Give him the chip. Switch it around.
你拿走筹码。给他筹码。切换一下。
OK.
好的。
And split it with me.
和我也分摊一下。
OK.
好的。
Now Mike will get the credit for the sale. He's at 15 again.
现在迈克会获得销售信用。他回到15了。
OK, yeah. Love you, Scott.
好的，是的。爱你，斯科蒂。
Scott kisses Mike on the cheek. Producer Brian Reed witnesses all this.
斯科蒂亲了迈克的脸颊。制作人布莱恩·里德目睹了这一切。
So you're at 15 now?
所以你现在是15了？
Yes.
是的。
Did he owe you one, or?
他欠你一个人情，还是？
No, but we always help each other out, especially on the last day of the month.
不，但我们总是互相帮助，尤其是在月底最后一天。
How do you feel?
你感觉怎么样？
Excited.
兴奋。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So amidst anxious salesmen and salesmen literally running to the desk or to finance, there is one salesman who is a model of calm. Even his cubicle is different from everybody else's. There's no swag. There's no pictures of family. There are no good luck charms. It's bare. The salesman, his name is Manny Rosales, says he doesn't like the distractions. One of our producers, Brian, who you just heard, got to know him.
所以在一群焦虑的销售员中，在这些甚至 literalmente 奔向服务台或财务部的销售员中，有一位销售员是冷静的典范。甚至他的工位也和别人不一样。没有赠品。没有家庭照片。没有好运符。它是空的。这位销售员，他的名字是曼尼·罗萨莱斯，说他不喜欢分心。我们的制作人之一布莱恩（你刚才听到的那个）和他认识了。
Manny is 58, born in Peru. He has gray hair and glasses. One morning at the showroom, he gestured cryptically for me to come over to his desk, as if he had a secret to tell me. Turn that off, he said, pointing to my tape recorder.
曼尼58岁，出生于秘鲁。他有灰白的头发和眼镜。一天早上在展厅，他神秘地示意我到他的办公桌前，好像他有一个秘密要告诉我。关掉那个，他说，指着我的录音机。
I explained that I was a radio reporter and I needed to record whatever he was going to tell me for it to be useful, but he wasn't having it. He seemed unimpressed by our little radio story. He said my colleagues and I were like fishermen who had no idea what we were angling for. We had no focus. We were just casting blindly.
我解释说我是一名广播记者，我需要记录下他要说的任何东西才能有用，但他不吃这一套。他似乎对我们的小广播故事没印象。他说我和我的同事就像那些根本不知道自己在钓什么的渔夫。我们没有焦点。我们只是盲目地投下钓线。
Manny, I soon learned, is a man of many metaphors. I put down my recorder. The thing you need to be paying attention to, he said, is the negotiation. The salesman is the tiger, and the customer is the deer.
曼尼，我很快了解到，是一个多隐喻的人。我放下了录音机。你需要注意的事情，他说，是谈判。销售员是老虎，客户是鹿。
The tiger has to eat, and you can't eat if you don't kill that deer. He moved his right hand up and then clamped his fingers around his own neck. You have to go for the neck, he said. But if you try to kill him too early, the deer will wake up and run away.
老虎必须吃东西，如果你不杀死那只鹿，你就没法吃。他把右手向上移动，然后把手指夹在自己的脖子上。你必须冲着脖子去，他说。但如果你过早尝试杀死他，鹿会醒来并跑掉。
As the day went on, I kept trying to get Manny to let me record him, but he wouldn't. Instead, he'd come up to me while I was interviewing someone else, point to his head very deliberately, presumably to his brain, give me a knowing look, and then walk away. At one point, we found ourselves facing each other at his desk. He asked me if I had read the greatest book ever written about car sales. I don't think so, I told him. What is it? The Art of War, he said, by Sun Tzu.
随着一天的推移，我一直试图让曼尼让我录音，但他不肯。相反，当我采访别人时，他会走到我面前，非常刻意地指着他的头，大概是他的大脑，给我一个心领神会的眼神，然后走开。有一次，我们发现彼此面对面坐在他的办公桌前。他问我是否读过有史以来写过的关于汽车销售的最伟大的书。我想没有，我告诉他。是什么？《孙子兵法》，他说，孙武。
Sun Tzu, as you maybe know, was a military general and strategist in ancient China. The Art of War is his magnum opus, where he lays out his tactics for how to succeed in conflict. And though Sun Tzu was writing about actual war, the book has become well known in business and sales circles. It's kind of like The Seven Habits of Highly Effective People, if that had been written in the fifth century BC on individual strips of bamboo.
孙武，正如你可能知道的，是中国古代的一位军事将军和战略家。《孙子兵法》是他的巅峰之作，他在其中阐述了他如何在冲突中取得成功的战术。虽然孙武写的是实际战争，但这本书在商业和销售圈子里变得众所周知。它有点像《高效能人士的七个习惯》，如果那是公元前五世纪在单独的竹条上写的。
So I went to the bookstore and bought a copy and then headed back to Town & Country.
所以我去了书店买了一本，然后回到Town & Country。
Manny, how are you, sir? Can I show you the homework I've been doing?
曼尼，你好，先生。我可以给你看看我一直在做的家庭作业吗？
Please.
请。
I handed him my copy of The Art of War, which I'd marked up with notes about its relevance to car sales. I could see why Manny felt that it spoke to his profession. Lines like, "draw them in with the prospect of gain," "take them by confusion" seemed especially on point.
我把我的《孙子兵法》副本交给他，我已经标记了关于它与汽车销售相关性的笔记。我能看出为什么曼尼觉得它说到了他的职业。像“以利诱之”，“以混乱制胜”这样的句子似乎特别到位。
How far are you?
你读到哪了？
I finished it.
读完了。
You finished it? OK. I want to ask you a question. What have you learned?
你读完了？好的。我想问你一个问题。你学到了什么？
What have I learned? Well, I'm here to learn some more.
我学到了什么？好吧，我来这里是为了学到更多。
And I was in. For two days, Manny took me under his wing with my recorder running and became my sales sensei.
我进去了。两天里，曼尼把我带在身边，我的录音机开着，成了我的销售导师。
Manny's kind of an unusual car salesman because he has no affection for cars at all. If a customer asks him how much horsepower a car has or how quickly it can go from 0 to 60, usually he has to look up the answer or go ask a coworker. He has no interest in that stuff. So instead, Manny developed a way to sell the customer using a different approach.
曼尼是一个不寻常的汽车销售员，因为他根本对车没感情。如果客户问他一辆车有多少马力，或者它从0加速到60需要多快，通常他不得不查答案或问同事。他对那些东西没兴趣。所以相反，曼尼开发了一种使用不同方法销售给客户的方式。
The psychology. How you penetrate his brain.
心理学。如何渗透他的大脑。
Sun Tzu says all warfare is deception.
孙武说兵者诡道也。
To help me understand this-- how to penetrate the brain of one's opponent-- Manny showed me a couple of movies on YouTube. One was a re-enactment of the Second Punic War in the third century BC, Hannibal's campaign against the Romans. Manny wanted me to pay attention to one battle in particular from that war, the Battle of Cannae.
为了帮我理解这个——如何渗透对手的大脑——曼尼在YouTube上给我看了几部电影。其中一部是公元前三世纪第二次布匿战争的重现，汉尼拔对罗马的战役。曼尼要我注意那场战争中的一场特定战斗，坎尼战役。
One of the bloodiest ever fought.
最血腥的一场。
At Cannae, Hannibal's troops were vastly outnumbered. He had about 40,000 men versus Rome's army, which had roughly 85,000.
在坎尼，汉尼拔的军队在数量上处于劣势。他有约40,000人，而罗马军队大约有85,000人。
The Romans will have the confidence that comes only with greater numbers. We'll present them with the unexpected and watch them fall apart.
罗马人会拥有只有巨大数量才能带来的自信。我们将向他们展示意想不到的东西，看着他们崩溃。
See, that is the secret. Present the unexpected.
看，这就是秘诀。呈现意想不到的东西。
Our forces will be arranged like this.
我们的力量将这样排列。
The details of Hannibal's strategy are a bit complicated to go into here. Manny had to draw me a diagram to help me get it. But let's just say it involves an unusual troop formation that made the Romans think they were gaining ground when really they were at Hannibal's whim.
汉尼拔战略的细节有点复杂，这里就不详细讲了。曼尼不得不画一个图表来帮我理解。但我们只说它涉及一种不寻常的部队编队，让罗马人以为他们正在取得进展，而实际上他们完全在汉尼拔的掌握中。
At this point, the Romans will think they have won. Let them taste victory.
在这一点上，罗马人会以为他们已经赢了。让他们尝尝胜利的滋味。
We're watching this, remember, on a laptop on the showroom floor. Customers are milling about, checking out the new cars, as Hannibal's mercenaries and cavalry encircle the Romans and trap them for good.
请记住，我们正在展厅地板上的笔记本电脑上观看这个。当汉尼拔的雇佣兵和骑兵包围罗马人并最终困住他们时，客户正在四处走动，检查新车。
[BATTLE SOUNDS]
[战斗声]
And now the killing has started.
现在杀戮开始了。
[BATTLE SOUNDS CONTINUE]
[战斗声继续]
So how does Manny use this to sell Dodge Chargers? Well, just like Hannibal would, he presents the customer with the unexpected.
那么曼尼如何利用这个来卖道奇Charger呢？好吧，就像汉尼拔那样，他向客户呈现意想不到的东西。
What they expect is for the salesman to be pushy and try to coerce them into buying a car at a certain price. So Manny does the opposite. He acts as if he doesn't even want to sell the car. He agrees with the customer, uses a similar tone, repeats words the customer says. If someone comes in and says he's just there to browse, not to buy, that's totally fine, Manny will say, and he'll back off.
他们期望销售员态度强硬，试图强迫他们以特定价格买车。所以曼尼做相反的事。他表现得好像他根本不想卖那辆车。他同意客户的观点，使用相似的语气，重复客户说的话。如果有人进来，说他只是来看看，不是来买的，那完全没问题，曼尼会说，他会退后。
The idea is to make them believe that he's doing everything from his point of view. So he's thinking he's playing his game.
这个想法是让他们相信他正在从他们的观点出发做每件事。所以他觉得他在玩他的游戏。
But he's really not?
但他实际上不是？
Absolutely not.
绝对不是。
What game is he playing in reality?
他实际上在玩什么游戏？
My game. Simple. Simple.
我的游戏。简单。简单。
Manny gave me an example of this that he'd executed a few days earlier with a customer named Julio, who was looking for a Jeep Grand Cherokee. Julio runs warehouses for a living and negotiates for his company, so Manny knew he'd be a formidable opponent. Julio told me later that he'd already visited seven other Jeep dealerships by the time he got to Town & Country and was calling and texting with another three.
曼尼给我举了个例子，那是他几天前和一个叫胡里奥的客户执行的，胡里奥正在找一辆Jeep大切诺基。胡里奥以管理仓库为生，并为他的公司进行谈判，所以曼尼知道他会是一个强大的对手。胡里奥后来告诉我，当他到达Town & Country时，他已经访问了其他七家Jeep经销店，并正在和另外三家电话和短信联系。
When he sat down across from Manny, Julio made the first offer, $36,000. The Jeep was listed at $45,000, so Julio's offer was absurdly low. Julio knew it was unrealistic. He expected Manny to say no way, that he could never give it to him for that price.
当他坐在曼尼对面时，胡里奥提出了第一个报价，36,000美元。Jeep的标价是45,000美元，所以胡里奥的报价荒谬地低。胡里奥知道这不切实际。他期望曼尼说没门，说他绝不可能以那个价格卖给他。
But then listen to what Manny did instead.
但听听曼尼反而做了什么。
I said, all right. If I can sell it to you for $36,000, are you ready to do it right now? Show me the money. Where's the credit card?
我说，好的。如果我能以36,000美元卖给你，你准备好现在就做了吗？给我钱。信用卡在哪？
Where's the credit card. Manny says this was the key move, the unexpected move.
信用卡在哪。曼尼说这是关键动作，意想不到的动作。
Because they never thought I would say yes. Suddenly, they don't know what to do or what to say. They get confused. He cannot back up because that's what he said to me. If you give me $36,000, I'll buy the car.
因为他们从没想过我会说好。突然，他们不知道该做什么或说什么。他们被搞糊涂了。他不能退缩，因为那是他对我说的话。如果你给我36,000美元，我就买这辆车。
[BATTLE SOUNDS]
[战斗声]
At this point, the Romans will think they have won. Let them taste victory.
在这一点上，罗马人会以为他们已经赢了。让他们尝尝胜利的滋味。
So he pulled his credit card out?
所以他掏出了信用卡？
Absolutely. He gave it to me. And I said, all right, let me take the offer to my manager, even though I knew that we cannot do it.
绝对。他给了我。然后我说，好的，让我把报价带给我的经理，尽管我知道我们做不到。
After days of negotiation, Manny ended up scoring this deal. Julio paid $40,000 for the Jeep, which was low. The dealership lost money on the car. But after it was all over, Julio told me that this move, when Manny pretended to take his low offer seriously, he said, without that, he would have walked out of Town & Country immediately, which would have meant no sale, nothing towards the monthly quota.
经过几天的谈判，曼尼最终达成了这笔交易。胡里奥为这辆Jeep支付了40,000美元，这很低。经销店在这辆车上亏了钱。但在这一切结束后，胡里奥告诉我，当曼尼假装认真对待他的低价时，他那个动作，他说，如果没有那个，他会立即离开Town & Country，这意味着没交易，对月度配额没贡献。
By 4:00 PM, the hustling in the showroom is paying off. Chips are going up on the board in Freddie's office. Even one of the guys in the back rooms is pitching in-- a finance guy, Terrance Kelly, TK. He's reaching for the phone.
下午4点，展厅里的奔波正在得到回报。筹码正在弗雷迪办公室的白板上增加。即使后台房间里的家伙之一也在帮忙——财务员特伦斯·凯利，TK。他正在伸手去拿电话。
So basically, the numbers are down. They need all the deals. So they made me call my niece in Las Vegas, believe it or not. She's been trying to buy a car anyway.
所以基本上，数字下降了。他们需要所有的交易。所以他们让我打电话给我在拉斯维加斯的侄女，信不信由你。她反正一直想买车。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Katie.
嗨，凯蒂。
Hey.
嘿。
How are you? I have you on the speakerphone.
你好吗？我在用免提。
OK.
好的。
TK's got 34 nieces and nephews. Katie is his goddaughter, though, so he keeps a special eye out for her. At the time that this was recorded, the rest of the family didn't know that she was pregnant, though he did. Even though he did not know, until he picked up the receiver and started filling out the forms for the car sale, her fiance's last name.
TK有34个侄子和侄女。不过凯蒂是他的教女，所以他特别关照她。录制这段时，家里其他人还不知道她怀孕了，尽管他知道。即使他不知道，直到他拿起接收器开始为卖车填写表格，她未婚夫的姓氏。
OK. Charles Parker? You're getting married to somebody with the last name of Parker? Oh, Barker. Oh. Is he related to Bob at all?
OK。查尔斯·帕克？你要嫁给姓帕克的人？噢，巴克。噢。鲍勃和他是亲戚吗？
What does he do, by the way? I never asked you. Ooh. HVAC company? Nice. I like that. Well, as long as he's happy. You're in the right area for air conditioning, I guess.
顺便问一下，他是做什么的？我从没问过你。噢。暖通空调公司？不错。我喜欢那个。好吧，只要他开心。我想你在空调方面处于合适的领域。
The dealership is selling the car to Katie below cost at a $900 loss. And TK is going to end up spending $1,200 of his own money to ship the car out to her in Las Vegas. And this? This is the sale that puts him over the top. This is the 129th sale of the month.
经销店以低于成本价卖给凯蒂，亏损900美元。而TK最终要自掏腰包花1,200美元把车运到拉斯维加斯给她。而这个？这是让她跨越终点的销售。这是当月的第129笔销售。
Just a few minutes before 5 o'clock, right after this happens, I stop by Freddie the general manager's office. Nobody is running into high fives. There's not even a staff announcement on the PA saying they made it.
5点前几分钟，就在这事发生后，我顺便去了总经理弗雷迪的办公室。没有人跑着击掌。甚至没有PA系统向全体员工广播他们达成了目标。
I've got to say, it's weirdly anticlimactic.
我不得不说，这非常虎头蛇尾。
There's no hurrah. There's no balloons falling from the ceiling. We did our job. Everybody earned their paycheck. That's the bottom line.
没有欢呼。没有气球从天花板掉下来。我们完成了工作。每个人都赚到了工资。这就是底线。
And then the clock starts ticking tomorrow morning on next month?
然后明天早上时间就开始计算下个月了？
We're all a bunch of losers tomorrow morning. You start all over again. That's how it goes. Oh, the wife. Oh, my god. Don't get married.
明天早上我们都是失败者。你得从头再来。就是这样。噢，妻子。噢，天哪。千万别结婚。
We're fighting because I told-- she says to me, what time are you getting home? I said, what time do I usually get home at the end of the month? Whenever I get home. What, do you want a time card? What, am I in punching in?
我们在吵架，因为我告诉——她对我说，你几点回家？我说，我在月底通常几点回家？我什么时候回家，我就什么时候回家。怎么，你想要一张考勤卡？怎么，我在打卡？
I said, when I get home, I get home, and I hung up on her. So now she's pissed and she's texting. "OK, so why do you have to bite my head off?" I told her she should've married a plumber. 9:00 to 5:00, OK? Weekends off, OK?
我说，我到家的时候我就到了，然后我挂了她电话。所以现在她气疯了，在发短信。“OK，那你为什么要对我大吼大叫？”我告诉她她本该嫁给水管工。朝九晚五，OK？周末休息，OK？
He texts her back. This fight actually continues for the next few hours over text message. Then, at 6:57, two hours before closing, one of the managers, Mike Perez, and Jason start huddling the desk, a little freaked out.
他发短信回给她。这场争吵实际上通过短信持续了接下来的几个小时。然后，在6点57分，关闭前两个小时，经理之一迈克·佩雷斯和杰森开始在服务台挤在一起，有点吓坏了。
Mike walks to Freddie's office to explain the problem to Freddie. Their count is wrong. They're not at 129 because there's an extra chip on the board.
迈克走到弗雷迪的办公室向弗雷迪解释问题。他们的计数错了。他们没到129，因为板上多了一个筹码。
There was a chip up here that was supposed to be pulled off.
这儿有一个筹码本该拿掉的。
What do you mean? We're down one?
你是什么意思？我们少了一辆？
Yeah. This was up there. It should have been off of there because the customer switched cars. But someone put the new chip up but didn't take the old chip off.
是的。这上面有。它本该拿掉，因为客户换车了。但有人放了新筹码上去，却没把旧筹码拿掉。
So I'm still at 128?
所以我还在128？
Freddie does know that, at this moment, there is another deal being negotiated that could possibly get them back up to 129. Peter is the salesman for that one. But the deal is stuck over the price of the customer's trade-in, what they should pay for it.
弗雷迪知道，在这一刻，有另一笔交易正在谈判中，可能让他们回到129。彼得是那一笔的销售员。但交易卡在客户的旧车抵价价格上，他们应该付多少。
Go make that deal right now. Whatever it is, just make the fucking deal.
现在就去做那笔交易。无论是什么，就做那该死的交易。
But that deal is not too easy to settle. And while they're waiting, more bad news. You remember that red Grand Cherokee that Scott and Mike Lester each had sold to different people and then Mike Lester's guy dropped out and Scott got the deal, and there was the kiss? Now Scott's guy also drops out. He doesn't want to buy tonight because he wants his mom to see the car tomorrow.
但那笔交易并不太容易解决。而在他们等待时，更多坏消息。你还记得那辆红色的大切诺基，斯科蒂和迈克·莱斯特每人把它卖给不同的人，然后迈克·莱斯特的家伙退出了，斯科蒂得到了交易，还有那个吻？现在斯科蒂的家伙也退出了。他今晚不想买，因为他想让妈妈明天看看车。
Freddie overhears Scott saying this to one of the managers.
弗雷迪听见斯科蒂对经理之一说这话。
What, you have a problem? What's the matter with it? What's the matter with it, Scotty?
什么，你有问题吗？它有什么问题？斯科蒂，它有什么问题？
The guy wants to show his mom tomorrow the car. Originally--
那家伙想让妈妈明天看车。最初——
What do you mean? This isn't a deal?
你是什么意思？这不是交易？
I thought it was, but--
我以为是，但——
Are you fucking kidding me? You have insurance on this car and everything?
你在跟我开玩笑吗？你这辆车有保险和一切吗？
I don't even-- he didn't even send it into the bank because we don't have his prior employer.
我甚至不——他甚至没寄给银行，因为我们没有他之前雇主的信息。
What are we doing? I thought these all went into the bank today! I asked you, all the cars have insurance and went into the bank? You've got to be fucking kidding me!
我们在做什么？我以为这些今天都进银行了！我问过你，所有的车都有保险并进银行了吗？你在跟我开玩笑！
Scott's deal is dead. They're at 127 with just two hours left before closing.
斯科蒂的交易死了。他们在距离关闭只有两个小时的时候是127。
I'm fucked. I just lost Scott's. I'm fucked.
我完了。我刚输掉了斯科蒂的那笔。我完了。
So now they scramble to figure out, OK, there was Mike Lester's customer for that red Grand Cherokee. Could they possibly give him better terms that would bring him back to the table? Freddie orders one of the managers, Mike Perez, to make that happen.
所以现在他们争先恐后地弄清楚，OK，有迈克·莱斯特的那个红色大切诺基的客户。他们能否提供更好的条款，让他回到谈判桌？弗雷迪命令经理之一迈克·佩雷斯实现这一目标。
Just do it. It's going to be too late. You're going to wait a half hour longer. It's getting later and later. I'd rather have a sure thing than not. Just fucking do it. How much does that lose?
去做吧。太晚了。你要再等半小时。时间越来越晚了。我宁愿要确定的东西而不是没有。就做吧。那笔交易亏多少？
Yeah. The only question is, how much does the deal lose, not whether it loses. So Mike Perez calls Richie in finance. Richie tells him he's in luck. The guy actually called back saying that he would agree to the terms but-- OK, here's the catch-- he just wants 24 hours to think about this. Mike Perez asks, OK, if we sweeten the terms, can we get him to decide right now? Rich doesn't think so.
是的。唯一的问题是，交易亏多少，而不是是否亏钱。所以迈克·佩雷斯给财务部的里奇打电话。里奇告诉他他走运了。那家伙竟然回电话说他同意条款，但——OK，有个陷阱——他只想24小时考虑一下。迈克·佩雷斯问，OK，如果我们提供更好的条款，能让他现在就决定吗？里奇觉得不行。
It's not going to change anything tonight. For me to pull down my pants, you don't need to.
今晚什么都不会改变。我不需要脱裤子。
But Freddie's telling me to. Literally, he's telling me to, so I need to just--
但弗雷迪在叫我。他简直是在叫我，所以我需要——
Bro, whatever you need to do. But I'm telling you, if I told him it was free and the same, you're going to get the same answer anyway-- 24 hours.
兄弟，无论你需要做什么。但我告诉你，如果我告诉他是免费的，一样的，你还是会得到同样的回答——24小时。
All is lost.
全完了。
And then, in just six minutes, they turn it around. Rich offers a better deal to that guy on the red Grand Cherokee after all and yes, he takes it. And Peter's deal that was stuck over the price of the trade-in gets unstuck when the managers suck it up and pay $1,500 more for the trade-in than they think it's worth. Back to 129.
然后，在短短六分钟内，他们扭转了局面。里奇毕竟向红色大切诺基的那个家伙提供了更好的交易，是的，他接受了。而彼得卡在抵价上的交易当经理们咬牙支付比他们认为值钱的还要多1,500美元来抵价时，被解开了。回到129。
Everybody seems a little stunned by what just happened when it's done. Freddie and Sal look out at the showroom from the desk like old sailors on the deck of a 19th century ship that just got thrashed around by a hurricane and also a murderous white whale.
事情结束时，每个人似乎都被刚才发生的事情弄得有点呆住了。弗雷迪和萨尔像19世纪帆船甲板上的老水手一样从服务台望向展厅，那艘船刚被飓风和一条凶残的白鲸摧毁。
Do you believe this shit, Sal? I feel like back in fucking Infiniti days.
萨尔，你相信这该死的事吗？我觉得回到了英菲尼迪的日子。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
This is ridiculous, this month.
这个月真是荒谬。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
This is just--
这只是——
The month wasn't bad enough. We've got to suffer a little more the last day of the month.
这个月还不够糟糕。我们还得在最后一天受点苦。
Un-fucking-believable. Fuck me.
真他妈的不真实。去他妈的。
Freddie's phone, of course, doesn't stop with the text messages through all this.
弗雷迪的手机，当然，在这一过程中没停止收到短信。
[SIGHS] God damn. The wife, who else? I don't know what she's even fighting for.
[叹气] 该死。妻子，还能是谁？我都不知道她在为打什么。
They get their bonus from Chrysler, $68,000. And because of it, the dealership ends up in the black, not the red, for the month. Jason finishes the month at 29 cars, almost twice anyone else, as usual. Manny has 10; Mike L, 15; Scott, 18.
他们从克莱斯勒拿到了奖金，68,000美元。正因为如此，经销店当月是以盈利而不是亏损结束的。杰森本月以29辆车结束，像往常一样，几乎是其他人的两倍。曼尼10辆；迈克·L，15辆；斯科蒂，18辆。
The used car side, Joe Monti's side, did not meet its goal. They were hoping for 70. They got 57, meaning Joe Monti probably will not be getting his year-end bonus this year.
二手车方，乔·蒙蒂方，没达到目标。他们希望能有70辆。他们得到了57辆，这意味着乔·蒙蒂今年可能拿不到年终奖了。
And Bob T, the salesman at the bottom of the board with the least sales this month, well, the night isn't over for Bob T.
还有鲍勃·T，那个在这个月销售额垫底的销售员，好吧，鲍勃·T的夜晚还没结束。
Where'd you put the key? Where'd you put the car? I've got the key. Where's the car?
你把钥匙放哪了？车放哪了？我有钥匙。车呢？
Not long after they reached 129, a couple walks in wanting to buy a Dodge Dart for their 19-year-old son. Bob T rushes them through the test drive, has the husband sit at his computer and use his phone to quickly call the insurance company and then runs-- literally runs-- to get their new car prepped and inspected in the garage.
他们达到129后不久，一对夫妇走进来想给他们19岁的儿子买辆道奇Dart。鲍勃·T催促他们完成试驾，让丈夫坐在他的电脑前用手机快速给保险公司打电话，然后跑——literally跑——去把他们的车在车库里预备好并检查。
Bob, is this one going tonight?
鲍勃，这一辆今晚要出去吗？
He says to bring it right over to service.
他说马上送到维修部。
Yeah, but is it going, or is it a paper delivery?
是的，但这在走吗，还是纸面交付？
I don't know if it's going.
我不知道它走不走。
Find out.
弄清楚。
It should go.
它应该走的。
Who the fuck wants to take a car home at 10 o'clock at night? You still got the receipt for them? Bring them back!
谁他妈想在晚上10点把车带回家？你还有他们的收据吗？把他们带回来！
These guys could say what they want. This old timer, nobody works as fast as me here. You notice that? Huh? Yes or no?
这些家伙可以想说什么说什么。这个老骨头，这里没人比我干得快。你注意到了吗？嗯？是还是不是？
And with that, Bob T lands Town & Country's last sale of the month, number 130, one car past the goal of 129. Or anyway, that's what they thought that night. The next morning, when everybody comes in, they look at Chrysler's official count on the computer. And according to Chrysler, no, their count was wrong. One of their sales should not have been counted in October, which means that they did not have 130 cars like they thought. They had only 129, exactly 129. Which means, yes, it was Bob T and his very last sale of the month that took them across the finish line. Bob T saved the day.
就这样，鲍勃·T拿下了Town & Country该月的最后一笔销售，第130辆，超过了129的目标。或者说，那天晚上他们是这么想的。第二天早上，当每个人进来时，他们看电脑上克莱斯勒的官方统计。根据克莱斯勒的统计，不，他们的计数错了。其中一笔销售不该计入十月，这意味着他们没像自己认为的那样卖出130辆。他们只有129辆，整整129辆。这意味着，是的，正是鲍勃·T和他当月的最后一笔销售带他们冲过了终点线。鲍勃·T拯救了这一天。
Special thanks to Marc Brodlieb and the entire staff at Town & Country Jeep Chrysler Dodge Ram in Levittown for letting us hang out for days and barely ever suggesting during that time that one of us might help them reach their goal for the month by buying a new Grand Cherokee. We sent a photographer who does celebrity photographs-- his name is Jeff Minton-- out to Levittown to photograph the sales staff at Town & Country. You can see the results at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢马里·布罗德利布和Town & Country Jeep Chrysler Dodge Ram（莱维敦）的全体员工，让我们呆了几天，在此期间几乎从未暗示过我们中的某人可以通过买一辆新大切诺基来帮助他们达到月度目标。我们派了一位专门拍摄名人的摄影师——他的名字叫杰夫·明顿——去莱维敦拍摄Town & Country的销售人员。你可以在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org看到结果。
Today's program was produced by Robyn Semien and myself with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Production help from BA Parker and Diane Wu. Matt Tierney is our technical director.
今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。本集的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自BA帕克和戴安·吴。马特·蒂尔尼是我们的技术总监。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. On a vacation this month in Rome, he stood in line for three hours-- three hours-- at the Colosseum then gave up, went back to his hotel.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。和往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。本月在罗马度假时，他在斗兽场排了三个小时——三个小时——然后放弃了，回到了酒店。
At this point, the Romans will think they have won. Let them taste victory.
在这一点上，罗马人会以为他们已经赢了。让他们尝尝胜利的滋味。
Don't worry. He'll be back. I'm Ira Glass. We will also be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
别担心。他会回来的。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们下周会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。